salute gentlemen
salud happy birthday my brother thank
you so many more
thank you young jamie thank you thank
you all
tremendous 53 spins around the sun i
have not [ __ ] had a drink
of the whole [ __ ] the hulk oven the
whole coconut not
you know i didn't drink before that
either no you weren't much of a drinker
it's [ __ ] every night i go home i'm
going to have a makeup because the
heineken makes a light
five points oh yeah tremendous they make
a double zero that
actually tastes good zero alcohol it's
the
heineken has for sure the best
non-alcoholic beer
really tastes like [ __ ] beer like if
you were an
alcoholic you'd be like oh my god i
[ __ ] up like
you know how you have those like i like
oduals it tastes good
but it doesn't taste like beer a cold
old duels is delicious
i like those non out i do some people
don't like them i like them like a cold
one it's really nice but it you know
what you're doing
with the heineken they kind of trick you
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
they're doing some weird [ __ ]
because it tastes like tastes like beer
well beer is like a taste kind of
that's that's the way duels work it's
kind of like that smoked juice you put
in meat like oh that's the
taste of smoke right or like watermelon
gum that yeah don't taste like
watermelon
it's still good but you know what it is
it's so crazy how beer
like i grew up on six packs and eight
packs
eight packs with eight ounces yeah nips
you got a case of nips
or a case of beer and then you went out
to colorado and they had 3.2
3.2 alcohol low alcohol if you're unlike
you don't
18 and 21. oh really that's what you
have to drink then when you turn 21
they give you the full dose they used to
be a club on the hill left uh
i forget what it was in the university
of boulder downstairs and that's what
they served you
3.2 beer right around the time i was
turning 18
was the time they made it 21 years old
i'm pretty sure find out when they did
it in massachusetts when did
massachusetts make the drinking age
from 18 to 21 i feel like i missed it by
like a year or two
but probably for good they were like
jesus christ
like i remember that when i was in
elementary people were mad about that
at least make it harder for them [ __ ]
animals thank you for the colder days my
pleasure
i did the blood test okay it's 1979
they've raised the drinking age from 18
to 20.
huh but when was it 21 oh okay 84. dude
exactly okay so 84 i was 17 that son of
a [ __ ]
and he raised it from 20 to 21. dukakis
also [ __ ] up he gave out furloughs to
prisoners and one escaped and killed
somebody
so when i got into a halfway house
wasn't it somebody when i got to a
halfway house everybody was mad at the
caucus
because you couldn't have furloughs no
more oh he used to
yes furlough about it was really
something or another right
i forget the whole story but i know that
people in prison were furious
because they couldn't go to [ __ ] on
furloughs no more
because the caucus let them go for like
four days like a [ __ ]
you know like club med for four days
he's a [ __ ] prisoner
i think let him go to club med and that
was the end of that dune
well they're releasing a lot of
prisoners right now because of covet
they're opening up the doors 18
california did you hear that one that
just uh
that came out of jail and shot the
[ __ ] who accused him yeah
yeah yeah i don't yeah i don't know if
this is the best idea kids
there's a lot of those people are very
violent like it depends on what you
letting out
if you're letting out some dude who's
sold weed you should have let him out a
long time ago
you know you're letting out some guys
selling mushrooms let that guy out
don't put keep in a [ __ ] cage with
people who are murderers
we've had this conversation before
you're gonna let the people that are
non-violent
drug offenders yes all of them
non-violent drug offenders
first time first-time offenders unless
you know this this you know what the big
thing in jail is sometimes when you go
to county
there's a big dui population really
there's [ __ ] that can't stop
getting duis
i think my ex-brother-in-law has the
record in colorado
i'm not making a joke here like there's
people
that stay in the system because of the
dui problem
you know they got to blow into a tube
before they start that car
yeah my friend robbie yeah they were all
types of [ __ ]
so and then they put you in work release
that's a complete different situation
then you you know they have different
levels of it you know
they're blowing in the thing it takes
some time too he couldn't just start his
car
so it was cold out like we were playing
pool and i go how long does that take
he's like it takes like five minutes
just gotta sit here
because he has to check to see to make
you're all right and you can't there's
no getaways
like if someone's chasing you you up
with the car you got to blow on the
thing
i had a friend that did that he used to
just pay people five dollars to blow in
there
he would get hammers come here what are
you doing blow in there do you know what
happened in chicago
do you have an idea what happened this
weekend in chicago no do you you know
oh about the crazy yeah yeah there was a
shooting
there was a shooting and then there was
some crazy looting they broke in the
tent
jamie was the first one to tell me that
there was like a incorrect story
the incorrect story was that a 14 year
old girl was shot is that what it was or
15 year old girl was shot i heard yeah a
15 year old was shot and killed by the
police but it was misinformation that
was and i don't know how that got out or
who put it out initially i didn't find
out that part of it but
it was actually a 20 year old that was
not killed and was in the hospital
so it got i don't know i yeah we're one
of those away
we're one of those away from this whole
[ __ ] thing exploding in
in different cities again why do you
feel this strongly about los
angeles lately there's too many people
very ever since the houston trip you've
been a different person
well i've been thinking about it for
quite a while i've been thinking about
leaving la for a while
because i think i don't this is just my
my my feeling i don't think this is a
healthy way to live
i don't think it's good for your brain i
really don't i think
the people that live here like i wonder
if it's a coincidence
that so many people that live in cities
have
like um it's like cities are always
democratic
right almost always cities are rarely
republican
and that weird like i don't know i mean
is houston like that that's a pretty big
city dallas is a pretty big city but i
think they might be blue i think the
cities might be blue
and then the states are all you know the
surrounding area is red
me and jamie grew up red i wonder but i
always used to think that was because
they were smarter
i just think that they were more
educated so they're more likely to be
democrats because i i
my family was democrats growing up and i
always felt like that was like
the people who were really interested in
freedom of speech really interested in
education and really interested in
welfare and making making programs for
poor people
and prison reform they didn't want they
didn't want the death penalty
they wanted you to have the right to
choose that's what it was always to me
so why the [ __ ] are they all like lumped
up in cities like what is that it's
because that's where all the
universities are
but there's some universities are in you
know in the middle of nowhere too it's
weird
it's weird how cities are like like if
you just forget if you had
a dog in the fight if just looking at
people it's odd
that these big giant clumps are almost
always the lean democrat
it's weird and then when [ __ ] like
what's going on now
happens where you have violent reactions
on a regular basis like on a regular
basis there's riots on a regular basis
there's crazy [ __ ] going on in portland
seattle they're trying to burn federal
buildings
this isn't rare this is like every day
we're totally accustomed to it if you
noticed
you see a [ __ ] looting in a riot and
a building on fire on tv you don't even
flinch
you don't even flinch they used to be a
big deal right remember like the waco
days
that was a big [ __ ] deal there was a
standoff
with the feds and a compound and there
was a guy who thought he was jesus he
was [ __ ] everybody's wife
and they had guns and you're like holy
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up
was waco 94-95 pix was alive because
hicks talked about it on stage
so it had to be pre-night i think hicks
died in like 93.
in that area it was like hicks and
kinnison died within a couple of years
of each other it was
it was waco and then the oklahoma city
bombing yeah
blew off [ __ ] waco 93 okay 93 and
then 94
95 was the oklahoma city bombings which
really
[ __ ] with me that week i snorted a lot
of coke the oklahoma city bombings are
very interesting very interesting very
interesting there's a lot of weird stuff
april 19
1995 was still living in boulder do you
see that building look at the building
there's people to this day that don't
believe that that was just a car
filled with some sort of explosive that
did that damn
the most thing i remember that you say
it's too uniform it was a daycare on the
basement
oh that's what destroyed me that week
and i remember i bought a big batch of
coke and i cut it and i was trying to
sell it
and i did the whole bag in four [ __ ]
days just watching the coverage on this
there are some [ __ ] insane people out
there and there are
there are people that are so insane
they'll plant a bomb
in front of a building and blow the
whole side of it they don't give a [ __ ]
who's
mcvay yeah and then you had the
unabomber around that time
look at how it blew that's crazy
so there was all these reports the
problem is like eyewitness reports after
traumatic events like that they're
always off
people always like you know they don't
know what they saw they're so [ __ ] up
and you could tell them what they saw
and then they'll repeat what you said
it does happen with people when they
look there's a big crazy explosion like
that
people so you don't know who's telling
the truth and who's but there was a lot
of people that were saying they saw
people carrying off bombs that were
unexploded
like they saw like the fbi carrying off
bombs like that there was more than one
bomb
and then the way it looks if you look at
the way the building exploded
the way they were explaining is i was
watching something on it
that the way one of those bombs would go
off
if it was uh just fertilizer bomb like
it wouldn't it wouldn't necessarily go
off that way where it looks like the
whole side of the building is going out
you know that it would be located the
blast would be
all the damage would be where the truck
was located
but being a [ __ ] and not knowing [ __ ]
about explosives
i don't know if that's true but it does
get interesting
like who gave him this information why
is he blowing up that building like what
what the [ __ ] is going on you could do
that with a truck and some manure
is that real
that's a hell of a [ __ ] bomb can you
do that
like could any crazy [ __ ] just fill a
pickup truck up
fill with fertilizer do what they have
to do to light it on fire and make it
explode and blow up a building like that
was it one guy was a suicider or
he just left it there and detonated it i
think he just
left it and detonated then they caught
him
the one guy that was a pair they were
part of a
paramilitary group in the hills of
michigan or something something extra
spooky about those
white dudes who live in the woods who
are plotting to overthrow the government
right there's something extra spooky
about those guys
and that's what you think of when you
think of timothy mcveigh think of those
kind of people
those uh you know those people like it's
a real sad story you ever hear the ruby
ridge story
no that's a real sad one that was a guy
who got in a
uh standoff with the cops with the
federales and they [ __ ] shot his wife
while she was holding the baby
i forget exactly what they were after
him for
i forget exactly what it was but it was
an egregious overuse of power
i mean they murdered these people and
the snipers murdered these people and
the people eventually shot back and then
i mean just a bloodbath but it became a
symbol of how
if you give people that kind of power
you know you don't know exactly how
they're gonna wield it you give people
the power to like pull guns out and
storm some [ __ ] cabin in the middle
of the woods
some people are some people are more
than willing to shoot did you ever see
this story
it's uh tony curritus
what is it he this was a live press
conference that got put on like
every news channel a friend of mine sent
this to me recently there's like a whole
youtube
series about i think it's maybe even on
amazon prime what's going on he's
really mad at this dude i think he was
like his mortgage broker or something
like that
he got taken advantage of and so he
kidnapped them it's like a four-day
ordeal oh my god and he took over all
the airwaves to get like his story heard
oh my gosh i started looking into it the
other day it was insane like i never
even heard of it was in like 1979 or
something 77
she's still alive i'd what's his yelp
look like i actually think he might
still be alive
when i looked him up i think he was
alive yeah holy [ __ ] this is the
creepiest start to any podcast i've ever
been on in my life
buildings
what the [ __ ] is going on here what the
[ __ ] is going on here
i just did a covet test i feel good you
know what i'm saying
and also they come into bombs and
[ __ ] explosions where's the happiness
it's your birthday [ __ ] very much
thank you very much happy birthday
tonight we leave we're getting the [ __ ]
out of here
because all you need to do is hook a
[ __ ] left on la cienega
and then hook another left on melrose
and drive and play a game
let's count the four lease signs yeah
and then
[Music]
you can't just shut things down think
about the last time you were at the
improv
close your eyes and think about the last
time you were at the melrose improv
now open them when you go to melrose now
think of the last time you were there
and think of how long it's going to take
for melrose to be like that again
melrose was destroyed already that is
why i am leaving because of things like
this
i see an 18-month comeback
and that's a guy with a ged i see it
it's going to take let's say we go
april that's assuming everything goes
well that's assuming everything goes
well everybody does the vaccine
or some people say it's going to
disappear november on on unlike election
day
just disappear
i don't [ __ ] know either but i'm
looking at this as
an 18-month recovery west hollywood is
going to be less
because of the supermarket situation
they had 29 infected employees and they
spread it throughout the community in
hollywood
west hollywood's going to be last did
you know that that all those bars are
going to be last so
i'm sorry to give you the [ __ ] bad
news joey you just
said got went off on joe about starting
this podcast off with bad news and now
you made me
feel worse because we're talking about
why we're leaving here
we're talking about why we're leaving
why we're leaving that's why and the
other thing that bothered me was
the knowledge ain't bad right now you
know like they were
like you're homeless for 24 hours there
and then you disappear let me tell you
something about burping going bird bank
every time i go i go to burbank just to
look around i got friends that live in
burbank
i go to two areas of birdbank i go down
magnolia to victory
by albertos and i see that
street is getting very eerie
like when you go on that street you feel
two things are coming
an earthquake every time i'm on magnolia
i think of an earthquake like
this is good earthquake weather for some
reason by the doughnut hut
and then you see those people lining up
for guns
there's three stores three of them right
around me yeah joe rogan that's crazy
every day i was driving the other day 9
30 in the morning there was a big line
in front of
peterson's trying to buy guns yeah
yeah it's crazy uh i follow all the gun
shops around me and they all have
instagrams of course and they show all
the guns they got in for the day
and i'm like oh you know i might i might
get one of those and then like an hour
later it's sold out like shoes like
there's a line constantly on all three
of those guys
how sad is that well this is what this
is what's sad what's sad is
i mean we now we know we didn't have a
plan if everything went sideways like
this
and you can't like governors
and mayors it's their fault right but
it's not their fault because really
get that [ __ ] job is a ridiculous job
in a pandemic
like all of a sudden there's a new
problem that's presented with you you
don't have the resources to fix it
people are not going to listen they're
going to want to party they're going to
want to still go out they're going to do
and you're in this situation where you
know a large percent
it didn't turn out to be as bad as we
thought it was but they thought it was
going to be a large percentage of our
population could possibly die
and you don't have the resources and
what do you do and governors
even though they they are in that
position they're in that position
because they got elected
they're not in that position because
they passed a battery of tests and show
that they know exactly how to respond to
any given circumstance
they were charismatic they had the right
money behind them they said the right
things
they back the right bills and then you
become a mayor and then you become a
governor but it doesn't mean you know
what to do if
things go sideways and no one knows what
to do and the fact that they were always
getting those checks
they're always getting those checks no
matter what happened no matter what shut
down
they kept getting those government
checks and they told all these other
people that couldn't work
like you can't that's not a plan that's
not a sustainable plan you can't tell
people you can't work but i'm gonna keep
getting paid and i'm gonna tell you when
you can go back to work again
because people are gonna go [ __ ] you
like you can't just keep everything shut
down
for five months that is california
i don't know what the proper response
would have been
i don't know but this wasn't it this is
wasn't the best case scenario and
again not a [ __ ] word about your
health not a word about taking vitamin d
not a word about exercise not a word
about drink water not a word about cut
out sugar
not a word about use this as an
opportunity to lose weight we have to up
our metabolic health we have to be
we have to take vitamins we have to be
better about our health not one word
everything's wearing a mask and you
can't do this and you can't do that
don't open this and don't open that
and look they weren't prepared that's
all is they're not bad people like
people think that they wanted to
sabotage
the the state or sabotage the city i'm
sure garcetti and
newsome are nice guys they probably
are fine to hang out with the problem is
nobody was ready nobody knew what the
[ __ ] this was i can't hang out with
garcetti
he says he says los angeles too much
leave it alone all right angelino's
angelino he drives me [ __ ] crazy
newsom newsome looks like you can smoke
a joint with him maybe and talk to them
and they'll go you're right
i [ __ ] up but garcetti's too what
about the [ __ ]
da's husbands getting charged with
assault because
what jackie lacy's husband is getting
charged with a misdemeanor assault
because when they went to his house to
protest that brother pulled out a piece
did he really said get the [ __ ] away
from my door and they took a picture of
him
and they charged him with misdemeanor
whatever i saw
the da's husband my god
it's just been uh you know the uh
mayor of or the uh head of police of
seattle just quit
yeah that [ __ ] tapped he sent
the letter out lady
well you know the cops they see the
writing on the wall for whatever reason
people decide they hate cops now
it's look there's bad people in every
[ __ ] job
you know the problem with being a bad
cop is it's it it can
it can ruin a person's entire life ruin
the life of a family
when you see someone abuse someone like
that like what we saw
it's natural to get upset we all got
upset
but it's not every cop and i think
that's a crazy way of looking things and
they're figuring that out right now in
new york
and new york has record crime man new
york is off going off the [ __ ] hook
my friend john joseph you know he lives
in new york he's always sending me
updates you know i dropped the [ __ ]
change it's crazy
and john's never left he's been you know
he's the lead singer the chromax
hardcore dude does triathlons and [ __ ]
he's not going anywhere you're not
kicking him out but
he's you know he's he sends me his
updates on crime and
nobody gives a [ __ ] it's crazy it's like
these guys
i mean the criminals they don't give a
[ __ ] they're getting they're
stealing catalytic converters in my
neighborhood
yeah catalytic converters are going like
[ __ ] hotspots
now okay so crazy i thought of stealing
crazy [ __ ] how much like when i was
doing coke i was thinking about breaking
into the white house [ __ ] like that
but who would rob a [ __ ] catalytic
converter right off the street
they melt them down the platinum they
sell it
and that's how they're making a living
studio city the last week
they've been hitting neighborhoods so if
you park on the street they clip your
catalytic converter i'm weird
but it's great everyone has nest cams
now and home security cameras so like
next door has become my new fetish of
just watching people's home security
of like people walking in the
neighborhood doing nothing that's crazy
let me tell you guys a fact our friend's
martial arts school got robbed here now
yeah would they steal she caught it on
camera
she dialed 9-1-1 they put her on hold
for an hour
what so you're dead
you're dead buddy
always call the non-emergency line by
the way and always press two
always press two you want it in spanish
they pick up quicker
so you [ __ ] unemployment dummies that
haven't gotten unemployment just gave up
the secret
you gotta i don't need another one no
more you gotta press two
speaking spanish they get answered
quicker your dumb [ __ ] you learn
something new with uncle joey
why are you pressing one it says say
press two
if you speak spanish the lady's gonna
answer
and you're gonna talk to her like
halfway like mino sabe
and she'll [ __ ] give you your
paperwork and next thing you know you
got your unemployment
but everybody presses one like a [ __ ]
knuckle think about that next time
think about press spanish and see how
quick they [ __ ] pick up the phone
isn't it crazy how everybody went from
everything's great the economy is great
we hate trump but other than that things
are great but that was like that that
was how the
country was and then all of a sudden
everybody wants a gun
same people same people it's because
people are actually scared
they're watching that video of live
footage
you know that scared a lot of people
they also know people who have died
so they're scared to go to work there's
that too right that compounds it
everybody knows somebody who's gone
because of covid or
knows somebody yeah that tastes
tremendous by the way i don't know what
made that what buffalo trace it's the
[ __ ] that is fun
it is delicious [ __ ] delicious yeah
it's very good i don't have to drive
i have nine more this [ __ ] is older than
america did they this company started in
1773 that is
[ __ ] delicious we're native kentucky
ah buffalo church you do two more of
those
they used to make they used to make
booze during the uh
when when it was illegal they did it
from additional reasons
i didn't know they had a weed scam like
they have a weeds camp today they just
have a boost camp same thing
you could distill whiskey for medicinal
purposes like a doctor could prescribe
it like brian
you need a drink thanks doc you go to
doctor and
cut your script for some whiskey i guess
which what the [ __ ] did they use whiskey
for for medicinal purposes
i used to drink jack and pull my teeth
out oh well i
didn't have it when i didn't have
insurance when i was a young comment oh
god if i had a toothache on the way home
i'd stop and get a little pint of jack
do shots
gargle with it and work the tooth okay
some pumps to numb the head
and you're [ __ ] good to go i used to
i it was terrible
something about losing your teeth that's
like extra creepy
listen to me dog from the cocaine drip
from all those years right at the end
nobody really caught it
you gotta watch an episode of my name is
earl
when i go uh i sing a song at the end
tim stack tim stacks what you gonna do
look at my tooth my tooth is black i had
already quick coke two weeks
and all of a sudden like a month later i
see that episode and i'm like
oh [ __ ] you gotta go dead i got a
cocaine tooth oh my god from the nerve
nobody caught it so i went to the doctor
for something different
it was like the 22nd of december
and he was like a beverly hills dentist
like this idiot sent me to like the
you know uh your friend's dentist jamie
from my name is earl
like he has the movie stars and [ __ ]
they send me there i'm no movie star
you got to pay 200 just to walk in there
so i went in there for something
different
and the doctor said to me what are you
going to do about that little
cocaine tooth and he goes yeah i had one
of those at one time
that's the best when dr cops are doing
drugs so
how many doctors cop to doing drugs i
got two of them
really stopped me three of them wow
one one that i grew up and i would see
him out of clubs
and he'd come up to me i was 21. he was
like 50 and he come up to me you go
what do you got for the head in spanish
in cuban miss
he used to say and i go
aspirin and he would go and they walk
away from me
my one family doctor whenever i went to
see him
the best 20 years is with my doctor i
couldn't give him nothing hand to hand
but i walked into his office put it on
his desk
and then i go to the examination room i
never gave him a blow i just came like
lollipops
and brownies i remember one time i went
in and he's like listen man
i found one of your brownies one night
and i hated holy [ __ ]
next thing you know i was making a steak
sandwich at four in the morning what the
[ __ ] was in that thing
oh yeah and then my heart doctor now
he's the best
that's the best doctor i've ever had
he's got three stents in his heart from
doing blow
he sold quaaludes in chicago he's a
[ __ ] nut but i love him
love him to death joey what do you what
do you think happens to the country
me yeah how does this when you look at
it how does this
even out listen first of all i'm gonna
be as honest as i can with you i don't
know what
red means and what blue means i've never
i grew up
hanging out with guys that were
democrats
i ripped signs down as a kid for people
i did all that political
dirty [ __ ] as a kid and guess what by
the age of 13
i saw the theft at the municipal level
i couldn't imagine the thievery at the
presidential the senatorial level
and the governor level i couldn't
imagine what the thievery was okay
i saw it firsthand as a child i was
involved with it
i saw the payoffs i went to long island
with this family
i saw all this [ __ ] i saw how things got
done
you know so i lost my faith in it
like i don't really believe and i think
it's all a bunch of [ __ ]
uh joe rogan's running for president
i got a drug that is going to hook
people
is going to [ __ ] people up i donate 5
million to joe rogan
joe rogan makes a few calls and gets
that drug passed
and every year i donate 5 million to joe
rogan it's a little more complicated
than that
it's but that's in the same [ __ ]
neighborhood it's in the same
neighborhood
it's in the same [ __ ] neighborhood no
i'm agreeing with you you buy yourself
into this so yeah you know what as far
as politics i never trusted
so this disclaimer as a politician
i'm talking about as a human being i see
a lot of despair i see a lot of fear
i see uh you know yesterday somebody put
a thing up
and they said that they shut the clubs
down in san diego
and i go thank [ __ ] god and a lot of
people
said [ __ ] to me and i'm like i'm not
saying because of that i'm saying
because the social despair
i think that if you're in a park i'm not
doing comedy
and the guy just went home and his wife
broke up with him
and all of a sudden he checks the mail
he's losing the house and he gets in his
car to go for a ride
you know how many farmers markets do
people get hit at with cars
especially lately people been running
through people lately
i don't want to see some guy run through
a parking lot in la jolla
and hit a bunch of people watching a
comic or car right now is not a time to
do comedy
you know what people want to laugh but
uh that that their their moral compass
is off
we're confused do we wear a mask do we
not wear a mess
is there a disease am i going to get
unemployment am i going to get evicted
there's a lot of things going on in
people's minds you know people snap
on daily basis is just getting caught on
the 405
about you know expect a huge amount of
people
losing it you got to be well grounded
yes thank god i do
copy you i get on i get up in the
morning i do some [ __ ] i do two bangets
and i get on a mountain bike i can't
hike but i get on a mountain bike and i
get all the way to cold water
beautiful and i come back and i get
vitamin d and then i wash my [ __ ]
and then i do what i gotta go do so i
get all that [ __ ] out of the way
i don't watch no tv i don't want to hear
it no more i mean you put cover
anything world news tonight is number
one watch show why
because they're just selling you [ __ ]
disasters they're just selling you
disasters i don't watch it
the tv wasn't allowed in my house till
six now to seven
and then i don't watch jeopardy a game
of fortune that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
because it makes me feel too old
remember when i'd call for you i'd call
for you at 7 15.
yeah who is it it's joey i made a call
for joe
hold on one second come in how you doing
mrs rogan how you doing joey
mrs rogan hold on and she's watching
jeopardy
so when i was a kid if you watched
jeopardy you were an old person so every
time jeopardy comes on now i get pissed
off
i'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing home
because when jeopardy comes on
seven o'clock you and i are getting
ready to go on stage that's a good show
though
that's a good show i know it's a good
show i don't i get like one answer per
show
it doesn't matter yeah i'm a dumb [ __ ]
but what i'm saying to you is
for the last 30 years you and i
at seven o'clock a certain adrenaline
goes into our body
and red band included you mean get ready
to perform you get ready to perform yeah
for sure at seven o'clock something
would happen to me that it would change
i'd go from being a dad husband getting
all that [ __ ]
i'm talking about the murderer i'm going
down the comedy stuff yeah
i gotta go sharpen the sword you know
what i'm saying seven o'clock you start
thinking about new things
you know the toilet paper [ __ ]
you know all this [ __ ] you write it down
you take a shower
i'd have my process yeah i'd do a four
shot espresso
i'd do two bong hits i'd take a shower
get all duded up
get in the [ __ ] car go over laurel
canyon i'd be behind him sometimes
or shop going down laurel canyon [ __ ]
tremendous
and also not got taken away yeah you
don't think we're suffering we don't
we're just
we we're learning to deal with it but we
got to take it away in the nicest time
ever for comedy
this is the thing like the people that
don't that didn't go to the comedy store
that weren't comedy store
regulars there's a image of the comedy
store that i think is from the darker
days
where people thought of the comedy store
is the comics are mean
and shitty to each other and that it's
like the industry never goes there
it's like a dark place like a dangerous
place but when we
got shut down in march that those last
few years were probably the nicest
friendliest years in the history of the
store people were so nice to each other
there's so many people that were
supporting each other and because
everybody had podcasts
like everybody kind of fed off of each
other doing that and so it was
beneficial to everybody to pump you up
like to let you like you let me know
about jeremiah you
you let me know about tony hinchcliffe
we let each other know about these guys
and everybody sort of circulates and
everybody does well together it was a
real
good environment man it felt good every
time you go there it was all hugs and
everybody was laughing everybody's like
i love that new tag or this or that
it's it's fun it was a good time it was
one of the most positive places
i've ever been to in terms of like a
community for comedians
it was super supportive and it was like
that for years man
like for the first year i was back i was
like i can't even believe i'm back
first show i did back was yours yeah
that was fun
and i think doug stanhope uh opened it
up remember he was just like guys
crazy show here yeah i feel my whole
time at the comedy store which is 23
years
was pretty [ __ ] good you know i
didn't come out here to do anything i
came out here
i was a criminal and comedy won you know
i used to be
i was a criminal and a comic and comedy
won
and beat it yeah but i always knew joe
your your thing was always that
you would come from a very unsteady
unsteady base
and you could tell you were like a
loving guy
but you had to get to know you you had
it you got it you had to get through you
and then and then you were a really
loving guy but there was just like the
bridge you had a cross
but i knew a lot of people like you i
knew i knew people like you
no not as funny as you but i knew people
that were like brilliant but crazy in
this sort of same sort of way and it was
always the same
thing it was always like their childhood
was all [ __ ] up
or there was there's a missing there
there's some [ __ ]
that goes wrong there and when you
develop like that when you grow like
that
in like such a chaotic experience like
yours
there's this is you know it's hard it's
harder
but when you get through you get through
with gifts that's what's interesting
about it it's like
it's harder for you than a person that
had like your normal
norman lock rockwell mom and pop sort of
a life
it's harder for someone like you it's
much more emotionally difficult you go
through much more
want for for love there's you're not you
don't you don't feel support you don't
feel stable
you grow up like that and it's it's very
hard to
write yourself as an adult because all
of us come out of our childhood which we
don't really have any control over
who our parents are and we don't we have
very little control over our experiences
when we're kids
but we come out of that [ __ ] shaking
like when we get onto the road
finally like not everybody comes onto
that road with the same amount of
stability
like some people come on that road and
like my mom is awesome my dad my mom
love each other
yay and then just going down the road
and other people like who am i my uncle
[ __ ] me and
i'm not coke and i'm only 15 and that
there's a lot of those people out there
too
it's like a matter of like writing it a
matter of like
getting it stable a matter of like
getting your life in a position where
you feel like you can make good
decisions and you're in control of it
and it's not the same for everybody and
i knew
when i met you you were a good guy i
know you i knew you were a good man no i
knew that too
i knew right away i didn't question that
but i
you were distracting yourself with other
[ __ ] i didn't know how long i would last
here i thought this was just going to be
a
fluke and i would end up in new york
selling coke and the story is that i
became a regular
i broke the record i became a regular
within a month did you really
yeah i landed here january 29th that's
amazing i became a regular february 19th
on my 30-something birthday
well mixie admits he caught you at the
right time she caught me at the right
time and everybody kept saying to me he
has mitzi senior that's amazing
so i didn't really go through the whole
thing so now let's go back to that
area that area that era was
hard at the store i had to follow up
mooney every night and dave
tyree and a bunch of crazy people after
eleven it got crazy in there
and then holtzman would go on and clean
the house and you know it was just a
different
i saw the three different phases of the
store yeah then we saw the other phase
with that [ __ ]
mutt laurel engine and his little crew
and i didn't go there for seven years
and then came the adam [ __ ] era which
was pretty [ __ ] goddamn special
pretty special he got so special that it
got overly special like
tuesday nights were [ __ ] just like
you had to go down there prepared for
war like tuesday nights when you you
ever see like rambo before he's gonna
want to go somewhere
or at the expendables yeah they always
see them sharpen their knives
and setting all the equipment up and
[ __ ] like
before they go to war bradley cooper and
the sniper
that's how we were on tuesday nights
like we
we had to sharpen our [ __ ] knives you
had to take your alpha brain
you didn't get high all day like you
know tuesdays you had to go down and
bring it back yeah yeah
it was pretty [ __ ] interesting and it
became
but then on the other side of that it
started becoming monotonous for me
it was like i was on the road or i was
at the comedy store
i was on the road or was the comedy
store i was at home
i didn't do anything else for like three
or four [ __ ] years am i mad at that
no no no no
i wish i would have gone to more parties
maybe yeah
maybe more concerts i wish i would have
done some more stuff when i went to new
york last year
to shoot the sopranos i saw my friends
and i saw how they lived now and who
they were now and we met every night we
went to a different
great restaurant for dinner and at a
quarter of nine they'd be yawning
and i'd be happy as [ __ ] that they were
yawning because i'm just as [ __ ]
tired
we're not kids no more and we would go
our separate ways and i'd go back to my
hotel and i go that was tremendous
and that's what you do now yeah but i
went out every night with a different
one to a different restaurant
and everybody has families you know it
just became something different for me
yeah
i wanted to go somewhere else i would go
to texas with you in a heartbeat you
know me dog i love you to death
but i want to go home i want to i want
to eat this
i want to go to somebody's house and
have the feast of the seven fishes
okay i'm sick and tired of eating this
[ __ ]
for the last remember i've been gone for
30 years kid
i've been gone since 83. i went back for
18 months of homelessness
and then nine months in 93 to become a
comic to do open mics with mike bishetti
at the new york comedy club across the
street from where castellano got shot
i played the game dawg then i went back
to colorado and got into [ __ ]
you know with the x and the bop and the
[ __ ] smack and the glock guy
and then getting thrown out and i ended
up in seattle and then two years there
then stanhope lured me down here
and i got a developmental deal how's
stanhope blurry done here
i did new years with him we're at in
seattle
96 to 97 he's like you're wasting your
time up here
he goes you're ready but i had worked
him like the time before that
so he's like i got bunk beds you're
wasting your time and i go you know what
i gotta go down there to shoot a pile
anyway cbs is paying me like 20 grand
how'd they find you uh thanksgiving the
night before thanksgiving in seattle
what were you doing i was on stage and
someone from cbs wanted you to do
something he was
from seattle he went home for the
holidays
and i got off stage and the guy's like
listen i've been looking for a guy like
you for three weeks
[Laughter]
can you read yeah okay meet me tomorrow
i'm gonna put you on tape i gotta pilot
because we want you to be
it was it was really [ __ ] up they
wanted my character to be spanish but
they didn't want them to look spanish
it was cbs's answer to nypd blue
it was a show called bronx something
something
and i came down and i was the worst
actor in the world
i started out with like 19 pages
all the cops and da's would come into
the bar and i would chit chat give
information
sell [ __ ] and every day that i went and
rehearsed every day they took a page out
every day they took a page out i went
down there by the time they shot the
pilot i had no
lines i just nod i was terrible i was
snorting coke i've never been to an
acting class before
i was staying until six in the morning
going there at eight what's his name was
the director
who's what's his name the guy who played
the doctor
you got to think about this one because
he's big time
he played a doctor in the movie with tom
cruise
with the naked women when the chief she
get he
the chick has a heart attack he's
[ __ ] a young chick
and tom cruise has to help him with the
chick because the chick is dead
he's a big time [ __ ] and then he
played movies what is that
what's that [ __ ] movie god damn sky
whatever oh yeah
where he sneaks into the party and
they're a bunch of freaks
he's he's married to the [ __ ]
australian chick at the time
nicole came in nicole kidman and him and
the coke kevin have a fight
so he's like oh yeah eyes wide shut
who played the dog that's the kubrick
one that's a brilliant movie but whoever
played the doctor
that he has the girl all coked up all
right he also played the doctor you
ready
to johnny sack in the sopranos really he
was the one that kept saying
i shot my wife the mailman and i was
already going down so i shot the maid
too
he was the doctor and he turns his
shades and he goes
uh he tells him dr friedman that guy
that guy he directed me in this and he
loved me in the beginning and at the end
he wouldn't even look at me
he would just shake his head i was i
didn't know how to [ __ ] act
it's hard how can you put me on cbs i
just came i've been doing comedy six
years
some people can just [ __ ] do it
then i got it no then i got it doing it
more but that was the first time
they say action i'd go what it's crazy
when like an athlete does it like an
athlete and then they're really good
you're like jesus christ
like how hard is it to act this guy just
came off the [ __ ] bench like
there's a lot of athletes have done like
who else has done like amazing jobs
the athlete thing is weird right because
at least
jabar [ __ ] rappers really stole the
game
queen latifah
actors are the best example or excuse me
uh
no acting classes no nothing yeah they
just took it by the horns they know how
to act
wait no one's better than that tupac
stop and think about it like think about
how many
rappers high-level rappers became
high-level actors bro two popsicles
some weird movies joe he made him
he made it huh juice which one's wasn't
in juice yeah i think so yeah juice what
about the one where he played the junkie
with the guy and the hot black chick how
crazy is that that tupac
was a huge movie star as well as a huge
rap star at the same time
i love the poetic justice oh he was
tremendous in boiling justice
dude he did a lot of points in janet
jackson did you ever see bullet with
mickey rourke
yes that was the most one of the most
ridiculous movies of our time
terrible terrible but it was interesting
to see the two of them together yeah
that was
mickey rourke
do you ever see how big mickey rourke
was in that in that movie
yeah go to go to that movie like there's
there's videos of it
like make you work in a tank top he was
[ __ ] chucking and the guy next to him
with the white shirt that guy was
married to tracy lords
you know him that's your buddy george
joe that's your buddy joe
i don't know you were with them one
man's the star he's married to tracy
lloyd i might have
you were playing the drums and jumping
up and down with it what are you talking
about vitamin supplements
what's his [ __ ] name i don't know the
guy yeah
joe don't lie to me he's not talking to
you look right there where
that guy was one of the best looking men
that ever
[ __ ] was in that movie with mickey
roy it's his son he's [ __ ] he's his
brother a photographer oh
he's his brother and he's [ __ ] two
chicks and a disco
he's i saw that guy who is he
that guy walking the dog find out what
his name is jamie please sir
do you keep that's mickey rourke no
that's the other guy that he's holding
hands with go down with that
now he's holding his hands go down down
here
that's
look at the half crop shirt he came to
the store one that he played mickey
rook's brother
in this movie and the other thing was
that he
was married to tracy lords
john enos that good looking [ __ ]
well he ain't that good looking no more
but in this movie
you would suck his dick back in 96
yeah he was [ __ ] smoking he was very
very good-looking
this is a strange movie dangerous very
strange movie
is that that dude who is that that guy
ben the guy who's driving the car with
the [ __ ]
he won an academy award years later it's
adrian brody yeah that guy
yeah okay everything was going good
they're getting a 7-up commercial
and they told him to get the [ __ ] out of
here how do you win an academy award do
like a shasta commercial
is that what happened something weird
they shut him down after he did a shasta
community
or something i don't know i'm just
joking i don't know man
you got another blunt for younger yes of
course thank you brother you could have
some of mine
no i'm all right because that's corona
test was tremendous i got one right here
just that swab in your nose i know she
took things out of my nose that would
we have to find out let's find out
what's keeping you going
make sure everything's i did the
antibodies test but then a dentist told
me she goes joey
the antibodies is no good the fda
approved one
is good it shows because whether or not
you've had it it's a respiratory illness
it shouldn't be in your blood so that's
what that's why she said that's why i
did the swab to be honest with you and i
didn't want to faint
i think that the weirdest moments joe
yeah but that's not real whatever she
just said that's not true okay it's in
your blood for sure
everybody's vouching that who gives up
the best way to find out right in front
of you right in front of you thank you
right there
the best way to find out apparently is
you draw blood and then they do an
analysis of the blood
but the the pin prick is fda approved
and the swab
lets you know if you have like recent
infections and i gotta tell you
right here because you know i'm a man's
man i know you're a man's man i tell you
the truth all the time i know you do
i made jokes about dana white's fly
island i want to apologize to him
because look at he did it right the
bubble worked
yeah now he looks like a hero the bubble
worked and unless
everybody adheres to the bubble mm-hmm
then it's not going to work for them
well
film crews are figuring it out now you
haven't heard from tyler perry any
complaints
no but have you you don't check your
[ __ ] a junk email
i do lately because they i get all the
saggy emails
and i gotta tell you something you gotta
read this sag [ __ ]
like what they have to do yeah that's
why a lot of them and they're trying to
do it [ __ ] you know
men's a mother and people are showing up
going this ain't gonna work
yeah this ain't gonna work tyler perry
already puts you in a bubble
he picks you up at van nuys you get
hired you go
do a test 16 days from when they pick
you up in van nuys
then you go to van nuys airport they
give you another test
you get on a personal plane you fly to
atlanta when you get off the plane
they do it again quarantine for 24 hours
and then you put into three groups group
a group c
group b you can't mingle with b or c
and you you got access to a mall a hotel
workout
little area outside everybody's social
distancing
not one [ __ ] complaint
but everybody's doing it when i found
this side i got pissed off
this is my life i've been paying dues
just like you i don't want to do movies
and i don't want to do tv but i got to
finish this movie
i thought that i read something in the
la times
that said that by adding covid to movies
it's going to add a million dollars
to the but like it's going to cost a
million dollars to do it properly
which is uh
have a courtesy hat so
for you for you to shoot a real movie
like that you have to have two nurses
doing culver tests
yeah they're gonna get better
they're hiring [ __ ] out-of-work
actors to get certified online
then they put them on the set to to
hold the test and [ __ ] you know
separated can't do that i pay dues
i want to [ __ ] nurse that [ __ ] yeah
you know
well it's the problem is if you catch it
and you are not healthy you don't have a
good immune system
you're older you're compromised maybe
you've got some sort of a condition
already
it's not good so the asking people to
work
where there's a one out of 10 chance
or one out of 20 chance or whatever the
number is that you might catch it that's
a new
ask that never was the question the
question was
hey do you want to work at ups i'm like
how much does it pay
what are the hours okay i'll do it it
wasn't like you might die
like you might catch this disease that
you die from it's not likely
but your everyone knows someone who at
least knows someone who died from it so
it's like [ __ ]
how bad do i want this job or you could
stay home and take 600 bucks from the
government or whatever it is
most people are going to take they're
going to take that money you're going to
downsize your life
and just figure out a way to save money
because it's that
if you worked at a supermarket it used
to be you just worked at a supermarket
it didn't used to be you come in contact
with someone that might have something
that can kill you
and it's killing people not a lot not a
lot but that does not give you any
comfort when you're lying there with
tubes in your nose
if you're one of those people that gets
it and gets it real bad like michael yo
and you're in a hospital and you think
you might be going
michael yo jeffy gueron
frankie big balls and chris
was sitting in the green room together
that friday night
they all got it except chris he didn't
get it no
really jeffrey got it hospitalized big
ball
pete uh lisa benelli's ex great guy he
got it
i think he was hospitalized and
as his last blog i read from him he was
on oxygen treatment
jesus and michael yo got it michael you
was here months later and he said he was
still uh
struggling with fatigue so he looked
great
when i saw him he like if you saw him he
would think oh he's 100 recovered
like he looks like he's ready to go do a
triathlon but he said no
he said he still gets tired easy it's
not it doesn't feel the same
that's the [ __ ] wood yeah this is
this is weird so
like i get it man i get people not
wanting to work
i [ __ ] get it i'm not saying people
should go back to work i'm saying people
should have the option
and i know yeah everybody man everybody
everybody should have the option this is
not a normal time it's not like
this is not a normal it's not a normal
scene
so if you don't want to work how much
does the government have to give you a
week
it's a good question this should be an
honest discussion that we should figure
out like how much money is there is your
right
to get paid yeah that's the rent thing
that's the red thing
you can't you can't just have people
broke like this for five months and not
even let them work this is what we're
seeing we're seeing people that are
there everyone has a hair trigger
everybody's ready to go off that's not
good for any of us
no no it's not a smile when you look at
the restaurants and the restaurants are
open you and i try to support
restaurants
[ __ ] tacos four times a day oh yeah
taco's 90s
oh my god it's like i abused my body
just to support them uh no tacos in
1986.
that's not [ __ ] that's how [ __ ] so
uh i try i try to support the local
restaurants
but i know they're making who gods
they're not making money they're making
dick they're keeping the employees open
that's why i tip as much as i can
jamie just handed me biden announced
harris for vp
okay kamala harris fearless fighter for
the little guy
now the country's finest public servants
as my running mate they might win
she's a powerful lady can you click on
her name she's very good at talking
yeah she was that lady that uh she got
into into it with tulsi gabbard
i know that one of them might be the
vice president of the united states and
i think that [ __ ]
uh trump won the election on saturday
when he gave people money because money
talks and [ __ ] walks
if i get a check in the mail from trump
after 600.
he bought my vote right the thing about
it is though i don't think
uh i think it relies on the state paying
25 percent in the state
california is bankrupt yeah like i'm
talking about the other day 50
he had me all scared of that well you
add up the state income tax
with the federal income tax it's it's in
the neighborhood of fifty four percent
absolutely with an increase
yes the increase that california wants
to do
look they they've tr they're trying to
figure out a way to buy the way out of
some of the problems
that we have i get it i don't know what
the [ __ ] they should do
i'm a [ __ ] i shouldn't be the mayor or
the governor i am not going to do it
it's not
in my wheelhouse i would not balance the
budget i would not i'm not a pay
attentioner
it's not me man i got things to do i'm
worried about space
all right i'm not worried about your
budget but somebody has to do it they
have to do it right
and giving them more money it's not
gonna it's not gonna fix it they need a
[ __ ] real plan
no one's telling us how to get out of
this economically no one's telling us
how to get out of this health-wise
everybody's bitching yeah this is the
first time we've been
caught with our pants i'm not mad at
anybody
i can't really be mad at anybody because
everybody got
caught with their pants down how we've
handled it at times
is kind of weird it's not just that it's
not just that we look vulnerable as a
nation
because we handled it stupid we
we had a big giant surge again it's like
we were
we were doing real well everything was
trending down and then we have a big
giant surge again now people are going
out
now places that weren't getting it or
getting it again
we didn't do such a good job it's not
you know the and the problem is if the
country's locked up
and we basically are a big percentage of
everybody's lockdown
and we're economically [ __ ] and we're
scared to do things
so we're like probably not that healthy
we're not not as healthy as we normally
are
and there's not as much money and people
aren't working well well what
this is not a strong country then like
the country is only strong if
everything's strong
like the economy's strong the military's
strong the government's strong
when the economy is [ __ ] and the
people are unhealthy
like that is that's the backbone of the
whole country this is a vulnerable
country
that's where it gets weird we don't ever
want to think that we're like oh we
don't have to worry about that anymore
but of course we do
that's history history is countries
taking over countries
history is countries figuring out a way
to dominate other countries
who knows what they're doing today to
each other i mean we hear about like
russian interference who knows what kind
of [ __ ] viruses we have
oh that melon [ __ ] thing is gonna be
a party and a half
that is the biggest scam in the [ __ ]
world
that is the biggest [ __ ] scam in the
world already the post office
is running [ __ ] bind never mind all
those ballots that's a scam and a half
that's a scam and a half and it's
terrible i wonder what the best way to
do it is though
what if it turns out the post office is
the best way to do it like maybe it
takes
more time but maybe they're better out
oh bro you never want you never stuff
boxes
for 20 miles and look the other way no i
never stuffed boxes i started trying
to stuff boxes well i grew up in north
bergen new jersey
what do you mean by stuffed boxes i grew
up in north bergen new jersey
i was a cuban kid that stumbled upon a
fight one day and stuck up for an
italian kid and they made me part of
their family
but the other part of their family was
that they were political
and he was the other side of the wing
for politics remember there's a mayor
and he shows up with a guy like you
that's intelligent but then he
also has a guy like me and i do weird
things for him
i let people know what is what the man
wants done
yeah and i got to be very i was that
guy's son
ah i was his son i became his son then
his son
died and i really became his son so i
didn't know what i was doing he would
just go
go light this on fire put 50 dollars in
your pocket
and that's all i went and did you know
what i'm saying he told me to go pick up
this i wouldn't pick this up he told me
to go do this i still remember
how i met most of my friends today were
from that election
wow the 76 election column a in column b
and i mean they were battling on the
street i don't tell you about jersey
knuckleheads
yeah you know we were throwing rocks at
each other and then at night we were
paid to go rip down your signs
and then the next night your people
ripped down our signs
and then whoever puts a sign of each
one on we all have a [ __ ] memory of
that
so if i side with joe rogan in north
bergen
and joe rogan loses i'm always gonna
pack my bags
because they're gonna demote me from a
teacher to a jailer
that's how they get you in jersey though
so they would all put signs on their
lawn for the guy that they support
let everybody know this is the way
listen you're my friend
they said balding you vote for harry
spohn he's a good man
they come to your house they knock on
your door and they tell you who you're
gonna vote for
listen you're gonna vote for these guys
it's gonna be fine
we'll take care your brother-in-law
needs a job to [ __ ] right
sounds like a nightmare place to live by
the way
that's hudson county politics that's how
he used listen in hudson county jamie if
you'd like
to verify no mayor in hudson county has
ever just
vacated they've all either been put in
prison
or died every mayor the active mayor
north bergen now is very good
he has changed the town his name is
mayor sacko he's very good
very good that town is clean bobby
cameras everywhere
you do something there's a curfew at
night very clean
in fact they just had a write-up about
the new york times
where most of the people are moving to
it's my hometown north bergen
then down the hill edge wall you know
lives in edgewater isn't that frankie
edgar
no he's in toms river he's in tom's
river hey you know elizabeth
who name a rapper jay-z
name a rapper he lives there iced tea
really who
naughty by nature i see all the knicks
all the nets all the baseball players
live in edgewood
oh so it's right above veggie water all
that hudson county hoboken where gino's
a cop and all that
oh okay that's hudson county they play
by their own rules gee
they do it a different way and you got
to pick a side
you got to pick a sign if you don't pick
a side and that side loses
boom you got to live in that hometown to
work in that oh no
and then they they [ __ ] with you they
it's a whole lot the wrong side
but it's tremendous it's a way to keep
everybody in line
everybody knows where they stand once
you go you go
those guys they put their hand on the
back of your neck
those guys they tell you oh yeah this is
this we're gonna do we're gonna do this
okay
and they're holding the back your neck
you're like what kind of conversation is
this like you're not squeezing my neck
yet but it seems like what happens if i
don't vote for this guy
bro one of the most interesting ones
that you've never watched but you should
read about
i think jamie has watched it's season
two of narcos
when they rigged the election in mexico
and they try to do it with the computer
and they get busted
and then they actually just sent narcos
to the [ __ ] voting stations
they put a gun to your head and go put
another zero next to that number
whoa in 1987 the elections in mexico
were so [ __ ] crooked because the
government that was coming in was gonna
side with the united states and that
could never happen
they were gonna lose millions of dollars
so that government had a win
and when you watch it play out in the
series you're like
but when you read about it you're like
what the [ __ ]
they caught him red-handed it's like you
catching me taking this
and you going joey that's mine yeah bye
and walking out of here like it was that
cold-blooded of an election
the the [ __ ] guy had to resign years
later but it was that brutal
because they figured they weren't going
to win the election in mexico city
so they went to all these farmer places
and all those [ __ ] got beat up
so forget about mexico city we're going
to lose mexico city it was what what's
the name of
the pera the the pra the pris an
organization
tremendous storyline on how they needed
that government to win
so they could keep getting drugs into
this country
and how the cia was even involved in
that election
but it was the narcos who went out to
the small villages
and [ __ ] put guns to your head put a
zero on that number
it is one of the craziest things about
being an american
is that we're connected to a country
that's feeding us drugs and is
run by cartels and everybody's like
bro they had a town in mexico during
this that the cartel said if they saw
you on the streets without a face mask
they shoot you
hmm it was such a small village
yeah that it would have destroyed the
village so the narcos got involved and
said
if you go out without a face mask we'll
put a bullet you had
there's something about people who have
power
whether it's you're the mayor or the
governor or you're the narcos or you're
a cop
something about people having that kind
of power over your life like that with
just a finger on the trigger
it's too much for most people to handle
it's too much
most people can't handle it that's
that's what you're saying
most people should not have the ability
to just shoot you you can't shoot them
but they can shoot you
you don't listen they can shoot you if
you're running away they can shoot you
you come with them with a taser they can
shoot you
they need to like like make a freeze gun
we could just freeze them
that's not a bad idea nobody could
qualify for life until you're a [ __ ]
cop
it's too hard to understand what that
job is understand entails
you know why i started going to jiu so i
could watch the ufc's and not feel
guilty
because i can't nothing bothers me more
when i see a blogger or an announcer
that's never done the jumping jack
and he's trying to cover the ufc nothing
bothers me more than that so
i want you to understand i grew up with
guys that were cops
i talked to them i saw how they had to
blow steam off because of the things
they saw
yeah they used their power they [ __ ]
around they were all bad lieutenants if
you want to call it
but the job itself unless you're doing
it man
it's weird that's so weird it's a weird
job
you live in a different world than
everybody else do i appreciate police
listen i've been arrested how many times
i've been arrested
a million i never have been arrested a
million times i've never had a million
point one
never had a problem with a cop i even
had a cop pull over the chinese
restaurant one time and let me get food
handcuffed
because i hadn't you got good cops and
you're a good guy
number three i've never said the word
pig
on any podcast when i went to jail i
went to jail on my own accord it was my
problem
yeah i've never given a cop a problem
when they interrogated me oh
i'll light you on fire if you want to
get interrogated you interrogate me
i'll talk to you about the cuban missile
crisis
i'll get you pigs those two white dudes
in boulder had him confused to death
i had him confused to death i was taking
him on psychological rides
let me tell you something the one cop i
faced on facebook and started torturing
him i want to see some dumb
he lives in telluride and he was
involved in the jonbenet ramsey case
so when i mentioned this name on a
podcast one time people started sending
me messages they go you know we go to
school with this
kid his kid's a [ __ ] [ __ ] right so
i feel like his kid like it became a
criminal but the dad has gotten him out
of trouble all his life the kid's a
[ __ ] criminal
so they taught the same people from
facebook hit me when they they go
your buddy the cop retired so i sent
them an email hey
on facebook hey listen congratulations
on your retirement
check out joey diaz on youtube
[ __ ]
and i know you read it but he didn't
[ __ ] reply you know what i'm saying
that's literally i put him dawg listen
to what i did to that dude
just there was two of them all right
there was a big white dude that
the the white dude this is the [ __ ]
crazy thing
i was not wanted but i was questioned on
the credit card situation
in august of 85 somebody had destroyed
that mall with a credit card
and somebody said i fit the description
so these two
cops with uniforms kept asking me
questions
i worked at foot locker and they keep
showing up every day can we talk to you
yeah the jewelry store said it's you
listen pretty soon
you know they didn't have cameras then
joe oh so they kept saying pretty soon
we're gonna start getting the receipt
and you're gonna have to go in for
whatever and they were coming every day
and shake me down
and i would go guys if i was a [ __ ]
credit card thief
would i be working in florida so i was
just buying time i knew they were going
to catch me
eventually that one cop even came to my
house on a sunday night
knocked on my door and said we're
getting the jean sizes tomorrow
you might as well turn yourself in i'm
like don't you want to get the [ __ ] off
my doorstep
that night that morning i went to san
francisco
a year later i get arrested for
kidnapping he gets promoted to
detectives
he doesn't remember me from the credit
card thing the whole time i'm sitting
there going
what is this [ __ ] cop gonna remember
me from the credit card thing
so you gotta remember i turned myself in
when i turned myself in dog and i
pressed that buzz and they opened that
door all the cops drew their guns on me
and said get on the floor because i was
wanting for kidnapping and kidnapping
too
they didn't know what i was packing what
type of person i was so they
handcuffed me put me in a room that was
white made me wait for a half hour then
they came in and played their technique
which i've been doing to people all my
[ __ ] life you know i'm the one that
would break into joe rogan's house and
steal one shoe
you take an ounce of coke and you steal
one shoe horrible
oh that's horrible and then you steal
that one favorite bad shoe you take one
shoe and you throw it away
that destroys people psychologically for
years they'll keep looking for that one
shoe
what happened and then every time you
see him you you'll find that shoe
no i [ __ ] searched everywhere oh yeah
i'm the [ __ ] dirtiest bastard i i
know how to [ __ ] flip-flop you
so these guys get you in the interior
get me into the interview room and they
ask me what's going on and i'm talking
to them like i don't know what happened
the guy showed up the guy pulled the gun
next you know i was home and they're
like so what happened to the guy with
the machine gun i don't know
did you know him i don't know you know
so how did you get
there i had a bike but you just said you
drove yeah i drove
to get the bike to i was just [ __ ]
with them because i wanted to get out
because
don johnson was marrying sheila easton
on miami vice that night i had to be
home by nine
that's all i cared about was this
wedding so i'm [ __ ] with the cops i'm
like i'm just gonna go in and talk to
them tell them the truth
that yeah i i went over there they were
selling drugs and i left
i had nothing to do what kidnapping what
are you talking about
so we went back and forth for like six
hours and i still remember them sitting
there like with their hands down
and me talking about like you know my
uncle came from cuba
in 1952 and he worked for [ __ ] this
guy and they're like what's this got to
do
with what we're talking about dog i
tormented
and then i agreed to give the guy
information
and i would just give him like red bands
drivers hey what i swear to the internet
i would give him jamie's license plate
jamie's not a drug dealer
but i would tell him that jamie was
running kilos internationally from
europe
they would [ __ ] they would go through
jamie's life imagine if jamie was doing
that and then they wouldn't find nothing
so they would figure out the [ __ ]
jamie
i was playing them i was just giving
them fake license plates how long did
you do this for
six months they thought they would leave
the real this is
telling you he runs big coke from
colombia he knows the ochoa brothers
no yeah so you were just making up this
crazy narrative
i was tormenting these two cops but the
one cop wasn't going for it he didn't
like me personally
how can i let him know that i didn't
like him personally it's a movie
it was a [ __ ] i let him know and i hated
him more than when he hated [ __ ] me
that's what i did i let him know that i
hate him more and every time we went to
court he would sit there across from me
but i had a good attorney and it was
burning him up because he wanted me for
kidnapping
but i'm like not dawg you didn't find no
fingerprints on nothing
sorry charlie not this time so he was
chomping at the thing he went to all the
hearings
and said that you know they're like we
don't see nothing else on the record
so if there's nothing else on the record
this is you against him
no it doesn't work that way he kept
saying i was violent
i was going to kill the community you
know he was one of those white
evangelist type guys
he even was so mad at me that he joined
forces with my ex-wife in court
afterward for like child hearings and
[ __ ] like that
that's how crazy it got oh my god he was
there when i went off one day
cuban style and that's the last time i
saw him
in style oh wonder the last time i went
to court
remember the last time i went to court
my wife it was the same judge that
sentenced me
oh no only he was in civil court now but
here's the beauty
i kept writing them letters every month
because that's the type of [ __ ]
i am you write them letters
from the minute i got sentenced to jail
what did the letter say how you doing
judge belapani my name is joey diaz
thank you for your sentence
i'm starting to learn what it's all
about to be a man for the last 28 years
i've been running a monk every month
every month on the first he got a letter
from me when i got to the jail i doubled
up
i got a job as a car salesman i really
enjoy it
thank you for giving me did he ever
write you back never
never but i wrote them letters wrote
them letters wrote them letters wrote
them letters i got out of jail
february of 89 i wrote them letters
i went in front of him in may of 95
and he was a civil judge and i was still
writing them letters
i told him i was trying comedy i was
getting divorced my wife was breaking my
balls
we end up in court in front of him the
[ __ ] boyfriend's got a steak over his
eye because i smacked him because he
called me a speck
so i smack them in the face it's safe
for it so they're trying to get me for
assault
oh yeah tremendous afternoon it was a
jose
and the judge goes number one you gotta
throw your case out because it's uh
it's a city limits of boulder you can't
use a racial slur
if you use a racial slur in the city
limits somebody just beat your ass
you get it's called the j.j flanagan and
number two
he then he attacked my wife he was like
listen
you [ __ ] uh come back in here again
with this [ __ ]
it's contempt to court and
so all those years of writing paid off
all those years
so my wife got mad the ex got mad and
i'm gonna walk out of there
was when i did something that to this
day i regret
it was that bad like how bad i went off
but it was four years of
getting tortured think of you torturing
me for four years
i'm financially done i'm financially
ruined
i'm trying to feature and i'm getting
heat because i'm dirty
oh i remember those days you know what
i'm saying like everything like that
that's the hard road so i was featuring
in dirty bars
but they would make me mc at the clubs
and they made me work clean and read the
announcements and [ __ ]
and some comments you know and they were
just like comics didn't want you on the
show
so a lot of comics didn't want me on the
show you know i wasn't that no no i
wasn't throwing the heat then no
i just was doing well i was holding it
but even when
when i met you when in the beginning you
were dirty
yes yes but some for some people that
that's like a deal breaker i went clean
for the first three years and it wasn't
me i was trying to be lenny clark with a
suit
i mimic lenny clark first but i like
bill x
and i love richard pryor shout out to my
friend lenny then he uh had a bit of a
medical situation come up
send them my love i know he was on the
show now yeah he had
he's gone through some uh medical
problems he's a good man
he's a very good man i met him at the
store and i told him exactly how i felt
and why i wore a suit the first three
years of my career but it didn't work
because of him because then
i opened up for him the second time i
ever got paid
first time i got paid warren mcdonald
took me on the road did a shitty gig in
the middle of nowhere
second time i got paid i did jay's in
pittsfield
opening up for lenny clark and i
couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it lenny clark who i
saw on tv
and i'm hanging out with him and his
brother his brother wound up giving me
gigs
mike clark still a good friend to this
day that was uh 31 years ago
love that guy how crazy he has his
journey it's crazy
i work for mike clark once in a
restaurant where you'd be in the middle
of your set
in the [ __ ] uh pa system would take
over
your microphone johnson party two your
tables ready
they would they would cut you in the
middle of your set and i didn't know it
until i got on stage
so i'm on stage talking to the crowd and
it just became the the funniest part of
the act was just
making fun of how pathetic my life is
i'm at a [ __ ] fish restaurant
down the cape and in the middle of
talking my [ __ ]
my bits get cut off by people getting
announced that their tables ready
it's like those car shows people just
start honking their horns it's like all
right
like somebody kick off this character
bert said they don't do that he said
they do that
like at the end when they're laughing at
stuff no there's a lot of uh
like amateur open mic versions of them
and stuff like that and that's
like you know you got people just
blasting their horn
you know mark norman said it best mark
norman's a very smart man
he said it best he said this is
methadone comedy he goes
he goes i want my fix man he goes i want
the real deal i don't want this [ __ ]
park comedy he said he did he said he
bombed in a park and he actually heard
crickets
real crap oh god that's hilarious
you don't want dunks you know what
i worked real [ __ ] hard i my joke gig
was i worked on wednesday nights in an
italian restaurant
where the guy was the cook but he was
also an elvis impersonator
and he had been an elvis impersonator
for 20 years in vegas
he met elvis he was the worst elvis
impersonator he was italian
he was 150 pounds overweight so he would
bring you the food and then he would
turn into elvis
i would go up on stage and do 10 and
then he would go up there and just
put all this music on and sing over it
that was my fifth year in comedy i'm
like what am i going to do with my life
every wednesday night that was my 10
o'clock gig
it was like 12 people in the restaurant
and he would go up there and sing his
own
it's now or never oh my god
and he was [ __ ] terrible and then i
would have to sit throughout the whole
show
he would give me spaghetti and meatballs
to take home which i don't have to tell
you
at that level it's like a steak it's
breakfast and lunch the next day yeah
so i had to sit through his whole set
god forbid he did an encore every time
he did an encore we get a heartburn for
an hour
please finish the song so i went through
that [ __ ]
you know that was i love all those
stories i love
the stories those stories those terrible
gigs
they make you better but you can't live
on a steady diet of them it's like
here's the deal like you can't do dead
lifts with 500 pounds every day
you'll break your [ __ ] back you'll
tear your knees apart you rip your
shoulders apart
but you can do it every now and then you
got to give your body enough time to
recover
and actually improve if you do those
[ __ ] terrible hell gigs
every single night it changes your act
you get
you get armored you you lose your you
lose your ability to like
take pauses you lose your ability to
like like set up a point
and then like really hit it home hard
like change tempos
you have to keep on them bang bang bang
bang bang drunk bars
you got to keep bottom bang bang bang
which is fine but it's not
you shouldn't do it all the time no but
i used
the uncle joey cocodiaz method
which was i had an 11 45 at the store
which meant i was really going up at 12
15.
i was a coke junkie there was no way i
was going to hold off till 12 15. are
you doing math
no no i got to write the plan out so
people see
that there's a method of my [ __ ]
madness okay so in those days felipe
espanza had a room willie barcelona had
a room
all those guys had bar rooms i knew in
those days that i had to prepare
two different sets i had to have my bar
set which was pretty basically dirty and
you had to go acapella because sometimes
you got to go up during the laker game
yeah you're not going to turn off a lego
game in orange county
they don't want they don't they love joe
rogan yeah but you ain't going to turn
nobody again
yeah or she's not going to the bruins
back in boston
it's not going to happen so you got to
wait for the laker game to go on you
know
how many little george perez fly
i still shout those guys guys out rudy
moreno
all those guys had early gigs for us
that fed us gave you 50 60 bucks
and then you killed time you stopped at
king taco and then you got to the store
at 11.
joe would be at news radio until 10 30
rehearsing
you would show up late and that's when i
first met you you were still rehearsing
friday nights you would shoot on friday
nights and then
you would do this spot on friday night
and i would go on after you
and you won 11 30. that was not
10 45 days yet yeah you were still
getting a quarter to 12.
i was very lucky i didn't have a social
life so i could just do you know i
didn't have friends out here
so i would just do the show and then go
to the store
and then hang out with those guys i
didn't really know anybody yet
so it was good i got a lot of work done
but that
the thing about stand-up is what we had
at the store
that was really unusual was also what
you were talking about with tuesday
nights
it was a murderer's row in a way that
i've never seen before like every night
you would go there
it would be jaisalneck eliza
delia you nick schwarzen it was just
murderer after murder
ron
ian edwards owen smith
tom segura bird crusher bang bang
those lines were [ __ ] death man you
would have come out
guns blazing and a lot of people got
upset at those lineups they're like i
can't get a spot i can't get a spot this
is [ __ ] up and they get mad
you know i i feel like these people
don't respect me and there's like this
talk we need more women there was all
this talk we need more this we need more
that
the bottom line is that was a murderer's
road
it was so hard to find a spot because
what are you going to do you got santino
you got ian
n words you got all these people back to
back to back to back that are just
[ __ ] killers
killer after killer where's the spotify
lighters
what is that from
you'd probably turn this volume down
here oh it's dead
what kind of whiskey is that by the way
i mean that's the coolest
this is buffalo trace is the first stuff
we had that you enjoyed and there's no
another stuff which i love warbringer
the war master edition this is josh
barnett's personal whiskey
how is it even possible to have lighters
in this [ __ ] place that's crazy you
don't want to use the zippo either
you don't no because you get the uh the
the fumes from the zippo
juice i had a lighter how do we not have
i had something
i gave them to you to hide i think and i
don't know he's a good hider
look inside that skull probably they i
probably hit him so well i stole him
from myself
uh i know look in the skull maybe that's
the worst
force comes to worse i have one in my
car somewhere maybe go to your car
because this is
this is not happening
how crazy is we got to set red band out
to his [ __ ] car
in order to get a lighter so i think
that's the first time you've ever handed
me breaking news
in the middle of a show it is very
important
breaking news the news of the uh i
i saw it literally within 45 seconds of
him tweeting it out
so i was like uh what do i do here maybe
she should be a great president
let's see let's just switch positions
people keep telling me dude he's not
there's nothing wrong with him he just
has a stutter
people keep saying that like everybody
at 78
is [ __ ] everybody who's not [ __ ] at
find me a guy find me a guy when i'm 78
don't take any of my advice
i probably won't know what i'm talking
about i'll probably be high as a kite oh
[ __ ] brian's got a lighter
when i'm 78 i'll be like tommy chong
high as a kite talking [ __ ] i love tommy
chong i love him too
um i've been doing comedy and virtual
reality and now it's the closest to
feeling like you're in front of people i
thought that makes sense
are you doing it like in a oculus or is
it a
valve index so it's like the best one
good uh refresh rate
can people record you yeah but i i live
streaming anyway so
oh there you go but it's cool to test
out new jokes because there's like 20
people there
and they laugh and they react they're
all like oh you know like spongebob's
excited
comedy is different with a small amount
of people there's like a there's a good
kind of comedy
that you can get out of a small amount
of people it's like you get an honest
comedy
because you can't put on like a stupid
show for three people
you have to like be you have to really
talk to them you know
yeah it's weird but you also don't get
those big bits
you're not going to develop big bits oh
no it's all tags it's all
tax it's all like new ideas and stuff
like that
sometimes you have good bits sometimes
bits come from that though
it depends really entirely on how fun
the people are the audience member
anybody says that it doesn't the
audience doesn't matter it's like it's
not the audience it's the comedian
you're [ __ ] crazy
you're crazy of course it's the audience
too it's a bunch of people together it's
everybody
like every single interaction between
two people unless somebody comes up from
behind you and hits you in the head
involves you and them interacting
there's a bunch of
you know a lot of pieces in place if
there's a [ __ ]
group of people and then you're telling
jokes of course it matters who the
audience is
whoever the [ __ ] said that's an idiot
that doesn't matter
it's it's not it's there's no such thing
as a bad crowd only a bad comedian
[ __ ] you you don't know what you're
talking about
it's funny i uh there's that peacock
thing it's an app from nbc so they have
it's free and you get like all these old
episodes and so i've been watching old
johnny carson episodes and it's weird
the monologue is so interesting it's
like it's like history like oh we're
going through the gas
crisis of 1979 or blah blah
but it's also interesting just to hear
them talking about all that stuff
like the old days and and like seeing
richard pryor on with betty davis like
they're smoking cigarettes while they're
playing it's wow so it's such an
interesting time capsule
that is yeah those days man them
bell-bottom stays
bell-bottoms and long collars people are
living different then
yeah i remember [ __ ] watching let him
in an 82.
that was my thing when i first got
turned on to let him and a friend of
mine turned me on to let him
and i thought it was the greatest thing
ever who's the first comic you saw
live yeah
the first comic i listened to i can't
even [ __ ] say the album
cover because i'll get in trouble i went
to my friend's house to listen to
the beatles and his brother was a junkie
and he came out of the room i was about
eight maybe nine and he came out of him
because what the
[ __ ] kind of music is that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you listening to take that [ __ ]
off i'm like it's the beatles
he's like [ __ ] the beatles and he put on
richard pryor
the crazy and my [ __ ]
head went off a swivel joe rogan like it
just completely went off a swivel
i ran home to the bar and i worked my
mom for five
bucks when i went to the album store
albums were 4.99
you know and i would just so i had to
get that out
i went home and played it i would hide
it from my mother because you could put
the album down
and then put another album on top that
was gonna drop
so if your mom came in you automatically
dropped
so she couldn't hear and then i bought
bicentennial
and that put me over the top yeah now
there was no dream of me being a comic
at this time
i just thought the things he was saying
was so
[ __ ] me like i wanted to be able to
talk like that i'm cuban
yeah i figured if i talked like that i
could influence [ __ ] and win
people over
because i had that little uh insecurity
about being an immigrant
but if i spoke like that and i could be
that funny
i could so i just started mimicking and
i would bring that out
to people's houses and the kids would be
ten and the mothers would catch us and
still today
there's a kid ray canelo his mother
still mad at me
for bringing over richard pryor there
were like three mothers that got mad at
me
for lucio fernandez that's a committee
man in union city
he told me and my wife at uh we were
eating one day
and he goes let me tell you something
about your husband he [ __ ] turned me
on to richard pryor when we were 10 and
i remember getting in trouble
because i brought the out mode like i
was that young
already into and then i got into red fox
and then lenny bruce got into it and
then i saw carlin on hbo
and that was tremendous and then i saw
freddy prince
and then i was partial to freddie prince
i related to freddie prince
because he was spanish so that gave me
like hope like kind of
you know maybe you know i'm saying like
spanish people could do stand up then
then he shot himself and i remember that
night the way like i still remember the
night that kid killed himself
like we didn't get the news like you get
it now
like i got the news when we were out
that night he had shot himself the night
before or the early morning
or whatever but i still remember him
getting shot
and what year is this i was i
had to be
74. i was uh i was staying with my
grandfather in newark
uh during uh the chico and the man days
she going and followed samford and son
exactly on friday night at eight o'clock
are you [ __ ] you talking to the
[ __ ] with a white pizza
sam for the son pull up a picture of uh
chico and the man
it was a good [ __ ] show it was freddy
prince and the old man
he was on top of the world too man that
was the weirdest oh my god he was
hosting the tonight show they were
grooming him
to take over the tonight show when you
hear about a guy like that taking his
own life you're like there's no way
and then you and i were driving from
dallas to houston
we pulled over at a record store and we
bought
a thing of him live yes yes from chicago
and it was terrible
yeah it wasn't good it was really bad it
was really bad
well you know the problem it was
different it was it was basically 73
comedies yeah it was 1973
it's 73 comedy not richard pryor you
know i mean there was guys like richard
pryor
that were to this day like if you go
back and listen to some of richard pryor
stuff it still holds up
it still holds up and jose feliciano is
saying the tank
yes oh my god yeah chico
donald trump whatever the [ __ ] i don't
remember
oh man i like that show it just made me
real
sad i remember thinking like how does
someone who's
that he's killing it he's got his own tv
show he's hilarious handsome is the man
the guy from uh
charlie and the charlie factor i just
saw what the [ __ ] oh that's not his cool
name anymore
[Laughter]
the old guy laying in bed with other
guys these [ __ ] were shooting
guns at the comedy store
him and [ __ ] pry i wish you well is
that is that cocaine man that cocaine
those guys guns
think about it he was hanging out at the
comedy store right man that kid
and he was at the him kaplan
they were all at the comedy store and
they were he you got to think he's also
super famous rich as [ __ ] 21
and doing coke this kid yeah
how old was he when he died real young
how old was freddie prince when he died
i don't even think it was freddie junior
related at all
yes that's his son yeah that's his son
how old is he
22. he was 20.
want me to tell you why i remember that
night specifically because i had
one on the way home it was so [ __ ]
cold that i had to cut through the
cemetery
and when i was walking through the
cemetery i had to take a [ __ ] oh no
and i went in front of a [ __ ] casket
the guy had been buried
in like 1920 so i go [ __ ] it he's got no
family left right it was
freezing joe rogan freezing i pull my
pants down to my knees i squat
i take a [ __ ] and i start pissing and
all of a sudden i go to get up and i
pissed in my own pants my
pants were frozen i had to walk home
like the tin man
because the piss went right into the
[ __ ] pants so my pants and i walked
in and my mother was there
oh my god and she's like there was there
was my mother would do surprise attacks
on friday nights on me like [ __ ] up
like she gave me the clearance but like
once a month i got a surprise attack
and that was one of the surprise attacks
but i walked in with p
on me and she's like what are we doing
here what do i gotta do
like what i gotta do i gotta are you
[ __ ]
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] what are we
doing here yeah like
i can't take this no your sidewalk seems
frozen piss all over his pants
what are we doing here is the funny [ __ ]
you could say everything my and every
time my mother every time i came home
with an idea my mother turned to
santoria like that's it
i gotta call you godmother i can't
handle this no more
when i started dressing up like bruce
lee and i had incense in my room
and a bowl of rice
oh i had the outfit the white shirt that
you folded
i bowed there's quite a few dudes right
i [ __ ] learned how to use chopsticks
my mother would go
that's it you got to go to your mother's
house you got a problem you're [ __ ]
something's wrong with you
you're not chinese stupid you're not
chinese
and that would make up reasons why i was
chinese it used to be that you could you
could dress like you
did kung fu nobody would even say
anything they'd be like that guy's
really into the arts
you could walk around with them little
skinny tiny uh black
cloth shoes with a tiny like tan
heel remember those joey they're
basically slippers they were slippers
they're like kung fu slippers
and dudes wear white socks and we have
the full kung fu outfit on
and they just walk around the street
like that and you'll be like all right
what are you going to do and then yeah
there's the kung fu shoes
i had those dudes just walk around with
those men
they would walk around with those shoes
and it's just it's a nice shortcut
to like instantly you seem like a guy
who thinks of things in a different way
you seem spiritual you're in touch with
your chi and your energy
you can talk about chinese medicine you
can say a lot of stupid [ __ ] if you're
wearing
those slippers and some dumb kung fu
clothes i used to walk
around with this my girlfriend's making
me do this right now like having outdoor
slippers indoor slippers
and like slippers i can leave the house
with that's a good move just for your
health yep but have three different
slippers and
the problem is if you leave your shoes
on when you come in the house you're
tracking all kinds of
garbage from the outside that is
actually a good move sure we're going to
taste
the kung fu outfit not so much about
three weeks before my mother died
she would never be home on friday nights
because she was a degenerate gambler
so she would hit the tracks on friday
nights
but every once in a while she surprised
attacked me i'd have to use the visine
i didn't really you know i would drink
uh boons boom boom swans
yeah strawberry hills strawberries
then i wouldn't really drink as much my
thing was the marijuana that was my
thing i didn't know i didn't want her to
catch me so i advising it
and i tried to act normal and and
[ __ ] i
i got high with this girl and i didn't
know
you know we were swap and spit and i ate
her monkey
and she was bleeding i didn't know i
didn't even know a period existed
i didn't know what the [ __ ] it was and i
walk in my house
and i had a little bit of blood on my
lip
and my mother's like what are you the
wolf man i'll never forget
she asked me
why no no did you know what it was
no i didn't tell her that i i was
embarrassed i didn't know what the [ __ ]
i was doing i was 15 years old
didn't you think she just assumed that
it was a
blood from a period yeah no wouldn't she
ask you if you got in a fight then
she asked me what happened and i was
like i cut my lip and she's like how you
know
how the [ __ ] did you cut your lip and
i'm like i don't know and i made up some
[ __ ] fake story
but don't you think she knew you were
lying she moms no
are you lying to a mom i did that once i
went to starbucks but i was like 35.
she caught me with a girl once and the
girl was hiding in the closet
and i'll never forget my mom came into
my room
looked around and looked at me and she
just slid the closet it was
of those sliding closets and the girl
was just standing there topless and she
just
get out get out full time and then she
would call them boys and [ __ ]
no no oh my god i used to date the girl
that lived in my backyard girl i used to
date a girl
backyards connected we were in love in
the sixth grade it's the reason why i
got left back
in the sixth grade i fell in love no sex
i fell in love no sex at all i just fell
in love with her
she made me a promise that in june when
school ended
we were going to start dating official
we could make out and [ __ ]
before that we would just hug and kiss
each other in the cheek
and we would play hooky and do stupid
[ __ ] and go to union city and i'd
you know spend money on her at [ __ ]
this little amusement park and [ __ ]
and one day they [ __ ] called home and
my mother answered the phone
and my mom started yelling and the
girl's parents were home
and my mom started yelling jos antonio
where the [ __ ] are you you're with that
[ __ ] from across the way
so me and her walk into her house
and her mother pulls me aside and she
goes
the things your mother is saying
i should go over there and smack her in
the face and i almost told the lady
listen
if you go over there my mom will break
you in [ __ ] half
you got the wrong lady she just stabbed
the [ __ ] three weeks ago
you're not gonna go over there and say
nothing to my mother
and i remember walking in and my mother
being pissed i wasn't allowed to hang
out with that girl no more
you know i was in the sixth grade
seventh grade my mom didn't want me to
be a freak
she didn't want me to [ __ ] have a
girlfriend she was like totally against
it like
i'm in the eighth grade my mom would
yell at me in the ninth grade
if i was in the bedroom and i had the oh
yeah yeah the door open
yeah no i guess it was 10th grade 15 was
when i really started
getting some action 14 was a rough year
i had this friend i had this tight
friend
called daddy let's just leave it at
eddie
all right we were tired i love daddy
eddie and me with tight he's the one
that turned me on to how to roll a joint
and he was a couple years older than me
and he had a girlfriend that was a
couple years older than me
eddie's family picked up one day and
went to miami
just like that left him behind left a
chick behind
left this beautiful german girl behind
so she lived on charles court
in fact she lived next to where the ice
man uh
the guy that was the ice man his the
murderer yeah the guy that was his buddy
the ice cream truck
mr softy yeah that's where he lived
pronge
so elona was her name she was a hot
german girl and on friday nights after
eddie left
i mean we were just friends and she was
way older than me
we were just [ __ ] friends and we
would watch chico and the man
and samford and son and
one night she asked me do you want to
make out i don't even know how to make
out with a girl
she we made it out together and that was
it every friday she'd come over we'd eat
pizza and we'd make out for a little
while
no sex nothing like that
yeah that took years years there's a lot
who was ice cream
shitty pizza i was just telling somebody
i grew up with catholic girls you had a
lot of [ __ ] around cats and girls
they weren't you had to go for it it
took a long time to take a
cat the girl's bra off but once they pop
the cork
off that champagne those gals is good to
go the catholic girls yes
they're the biggest freaks but the first
night is not good
they cry you gotta walk them home and
rub their back
and tell them they're not gonna go to
hell because that's the big thing they
said about going to hell
i think with the internet they're not
they're less likely to worry about going
to hell
no no i'm talking about 19. you know i
was there catholic girls i had one
girlfriend that that happened
and it was the longest night of my
[ __ ] life i had one in eighty-two she
called me when she got home
this is seventy [ __ ] eight all right
and she went to all girls academy
you understand me so i played at saint
michael's cyo
okay the home of tommy [ __ ]
heinz
if anybody who knows anything hey
uh so uh and she went to the school that
cheerleaded for us so i dated and
eventually
you know something happened and it was
brutal
it was brutal crying the crying
terrible days guilt that she go to hell
because
i had the same guilt bro i could not
believe it after that i went straight
i was like this isn't gonna happen again
till i marry a woman that's how [ __ ]
catholic i was guys
the crazy thing is they didn't tell us
anything
about birth control they didn't tell a
[ __ ] no
people everybody was already [ __ ]
before anybody got to talk to
everybody was already [ __ ] by the
time they were 16. when you're 17 your
dad
or your mom or school someone's going to
pull you aside and say well if you're
going to have sex like
gonna like everybody around you is
[ __ ] you leave these 16 17 year olds
together
they go to birthday parties together
they're drinking
everybody's [ __ ] they're [ __ ] when
they're 16 all the time
that's so normal i don't know what
age people [ __ ] at when they were like
in the 1950s
when our parents were growing up i don't
know what desi and lucy didn't [ __ ] they
slept in separate beds
all those tv shows they slept in the
september do you think people did less
[ __ ] or did
do you think they did less talking they
[ __ ] themselves
they [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of marilyn
monroe didn't they
they [ __ ] that poor woman to death
almost bro
i know this dude that you know
that marilyn monroe [ __ ] him when he
was 16
and she was 22. oh yeah we know that
dude you know what i'm talking about
he played uh he was the guy in and that
should we give him up
huh tom hanks no
[Laughter]
it wasn't time man it's your boy no it's
jesus that's why he's trying to get out
of here
it's gianni whatever the guy that sonny
beats up and the godfather yeah
you didn't know that um i think i did
yeah
it's the guy that sonny beat there's a
lot my memory is full
it's really full like over this lap i
mean i know i'm 53 so i'm like
officially old now i've been officially
owed for at least eight years
but like now like officially officially
old like my memory is full
it's like i can still pull stuff up that
i know but like the new stuff it's hard
to get in there and there's a lot of old
stuff i'm just deleting
left and right i forget what i have for
lunch but if you read
if you read the article i told you to
read a long time ago which one
the one about uh johnny russo said he
lost his virginity marilyn rowe at 15.
that's what's up see this is the
difference if that's some horrible man
who did that to a 15 year old girl it's
a crime but we're all excited for him
imagine you're a 15 year old and married
[Music]
can you imagine today one of these
mothers from studio city i want to speak
to an officer
marilyn monroe [ __ ] my my son the cop
wouldn't even smack her in the face
shut the [ __ ] up you dummy that kid's so
lucky
he [ __ ] he's so lucky he's so lucky
about that she probably sat on his face
some guys that have like this weird
relationship jason priestley was in it i
think oh no [ __ ]
in the 90s i don't remember that it's
probably not about that movie but it's
like a
dramatized version of like a young dude
in our relationship with marilyn monroe
that's hilarious
listen man i think it's amazing that she
was willing to do that
i think it's amazing she'd find some 15
year old kid and go i'm gonna freak this
[ __ ] kid out
i'm marilyn monroe i'm gonna [ __ ] a
gardener i'm gonna [ __ ] some 15 year old
kid
pushing a lawn mower let's do it baby
you imagine
you're on the couch 15 year old kid and
marilyn monroe just grabs your dick and
sticks inside of her you're like what
how how is this happy you remember that
iconic video of her standing from on the
subway great
in manhattan it's blown or skirt up and
here's marilyn monroe riding you
can you imagine him telling his friends
and they're like get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
you didn't [ __ ] no maryland
so full of [ __ ] you won't believe his
latest lie
what if she was that gross though she
was just so drugged up and drunk that
people were like ooh get her away from
me let me like put her over next to that
15 year old kid
brian there's video of her before she
died this video of her
the year that she was still alive before
she died she was beautiful that movie
was based off of
this like that old i had a secret show
it's like the guy went on and said i had
a date with marilyn monroe
and she paid for it oh my god movie came
out in 1993.
dude i have so much more respect for her
now i just think if i was a female
famous actor that'd be the most gangster
thing to do
[ __ ] high school seniors just grab them
get in the limo [ __ ]
no one would no one would have a problem
with it
no one would have a problem with it
everybody would have a problem with
everything we would all be laughing
though but if if
you know if like the biggest movie star
in the world was scooping up high school
seniors and blowing them
nobody would nobody get mad they would
say that's crazy i think that's
happening there was a gym teacher in my
school
that no one's at school right now there
was a female there was a female gym
teacher in my school
that [ __ ] everybody didn't [ __ ] me she
didn't like me
she [ __ ] everybody we used to drop
people off in the house
you've been dropped like red man where
you going you guys got to drop me off at
miss
whatever's house and she would just [ __ ]
the kids yeah how old
she had to be in her 30s no how old were
the kids 16
15 17. whoever's ready to party
everybody gave her a [ __ ] stab
now dude everybody talk about it how
many people are
well known did the teachers know about
it or do the kids keep their mouth shut
cause that's the difference between
today i think she was giving [ __ ] to
the teachers too
she ended up marrying one of the
teachers did she i don't i'm not sure
she was a hot blonde she was a hot
blonde
and then there was a chick in our high
school that just liked older guys
and i remember we were in summer school
and we were standing outside
and this chick was [ __ ] hammered
she had to be 16 15 my age sophomore
summer
and right in front of everybody she just
went up to the vice principal hammond
and just started grabbing his dick and
going let's get out of here baby and
he's like
all right everybody could go play now
and
[ __ ] it he's just froze i know the girl
i see i'm friends with her on facebook
today
really she's got kids yeah wow she got
kids the whole [ __ ] deal and i talked
to her from time to time saying hello
that's hilarious
she was a freak when i was a kid there
was always a neighborhood freak
there was a neighborhood freak in my
neighborhood [ __ ] all the kids that
played softball
she was hot she was 21. always had torn
jeans
they always knew a lot about rock they
always introduced you to some
old sabbath she'd play some old zeppelin
like i didn't know i i you know i was
musically illiterate at the point
i learned a lot about music from this
lady she's a nice lady does she smell
like cigarettes
oh yeah yeah yeah i thought it was hot
my street girl smelled like cigarettes i
thought it was hot i thought girls would
smell like like a woman that smelled
like she smoked cigarettes it was hot
this is like a dangerous lady
doesn't give a [ __ ] about cancer
that's my rationale when i was a kid
i didn't i thought it was the dumbest
thing for you to do for your health but
i also thought it was hot
if girls smoke cigarettes i'll tell you
what the the how hard it was in my
neighborhood to score
that on facebook most of the kids on
friends were from my neighborhood
are married they married their high
school sweethearts
that's how anti-sex not anti-sex
but that's my high school was very
old-school old-fashioned it was very
old-fashioned yeah
high school sweetheart if you took a
spanish girl on a date you had to go
with a grandmother first three or four
nights
italian girls sometimes you got to bring
the whale you know the grandma with you
it was a different time i didn't learn
about sugar daddies and all that [ __ ]
i moved to seattle i heard all that
nonsense yeah
and then the [ __ ] that you hear once you
move here i've never been raised around
that [ __ ] i'm a criminal i don't know
nothing about that
[ __ ] yeah islands and tom hanks
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
oh and you hear this [ __ ] you know the
epstein
i don't know i don't know what to
believe i don't know but i don't think
tom hanks is a part of that
tom hanks thing is more or less an
internet meme it's like a joke that
they're they're pretending that tom
hanks the pedophile
but the uh i've seen things real that's
that's what's crazy it's like there's so
much talk
about all these other things when
there's
there's a whole log of people that went
to this island
with a guy who was a pedophile who was
known for having underage girls
and he didn't really kill himself and
everybody knows it so
everybody knows somebody what's the over
i took the over that they're gonna bomb
that place where they have it
they can't they can't choke her no they
can't choke and they can't
suicide so there's either going to be
some type of
disruption corona some type of
disruption
corona some a heavy dose of corona
well that was one of the things i talked
to oliver stone about with jack ruby you
said that jack ruby getting cancer and
dying so quickly
like that didn't really make sense that
they were working on things that you
could do to people where you could
inject them and they'd get cancer and
die
yeah yeah corona there's either who
knows
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens it's gonna blow her out of there
if
she has to testify the [ __ ] marines
got to go
yeah the marines got to go e-bike
accident
[Laughter]
like poor simon
broke his back what he was on though
like i have two e-bikes i'm addicted to
that lifestyle but what he was on
is is like a motorbike it's like a tron
motorcycle that's has like the torque of
a tesla you know
no it's like he was on one of those one
of those what's he doing
uh i don't know i think uh no helmet
i think it's fun it's like having a test
as a bike and
but is it a is it a motorcycle or is it
a scooter do you need a license
classified yeah instead of like a
motorbike like x game style it's just
uh a battery when we were in austin i
was watching those drunk [ __ ]
roll by on those scooters i was like do
you need a license for that you should
have a [ __ ]
license these guys are going kind of
fast you do you're supposed to you why'd
you when you sign up for the thing
you're supposed to like take a picture
of your id and
if you fall going 15 miles an hour you
are
[ __ ] like i don't know if you realize
how [ __ ] you are if you fall on
concrete and you're going 15 miles an
hour you're [ __ ] one of mine goes 38.
38. yeah and it's just like yeah jamie's
got a crazy one you got to know how to
fall
listen [ __ ] you're hitting the concrete
and electric poles it hurts
oh my god stop you don't understand if
you hit something at 30 miles an hour
that's way different than okay let's say
15. something at 15 miles an hour you
hit the concrete
and a pole at 15 miles an hour you have
no understanding of what you would weigh
with 200 pounds the ones you rent off
the street
have a limp they're limited to only go
like 13 miles an hour or something like
that if you hit a pole at 13 miles an
hour
listen to me jamie you're gonna get
[ __ ] up
you're gonna get [ __ ] up like really
[ __ ] up that's full sprint i know
i get it but i'm saying like you if
you're just walking around
it's not nearly well you don't but other
folks are intoxicated you're very well
coordinated
but i'm saying it's kind of crazy you
could just pick one of these things up
with no license
and you're going 15 miles an hour poking
down the streets these are the ones that
you these are the ones you rent on the
street
you're supposed to have a license you
have to have a license whether or not
you do it without like you can give it
to your kid but like as you sign up for
it
you're live you're giving a liability
like you take a picture of your license
oh okay so you have to have a driver's
license yeah yeah yeah okay
not buying them that's better yeah
that's to buy it that's better but but
it's definitely more complicated than
driving a car right like you got a
balance on that thing
a bike you but if someone's a slob
right it's not hard but it's a sloth
balance if someone just has no
coordination
it's just like i get on one of those
things it's just a bike that scooter
oh scooter those scooters that are
everywhere yeah i don't like the
scooters you can go fast
yeah you can go as fast there's scooters
that go 45 miles an hour that you could
buy
come on you can't do that you need a
helmet where's your [ __ ] helmet
you definitely you're going 40 miles an
hour where's your helmet
it's real common though but listen at
least
if people fall down they're not well you
could [ __ ] wipe into somebody
you could wipe into somebody and hurt
them pretty bad keep your eyes open
they banned them in hoboken they banned
them they banned them because they were
being dropped all over the place and
people were hurting themselves
that's just another [ __ ] headache for
people it's weird because you can just
leave him on the sidewalk
you leave him on the side people are
doing them at night
yeah you know you're taking a chance
every time you get on one of those
[ __ ] things
it's it's a [ __ ] nightmare
i support people's right to do it no i
don't give a [ __ ] let them do it but
don't come crying to me
when you get hit in the [ __ ] by a truck
yeah don't come crying to me then
i wouldn't advise any of my friends
especially if they're intoxicated
like you didn't take this home no if
you're thinking
should i take this home you definitely
shouldn't take that home because a
mistake
one [ __ ] mistake dog listen joe rogan
you get dewey on this too i think
what's that operating while it's
intoxicating oh yeah and you yeah yeah
absolutely that makes sense my brother
of course my brother i took a bike
riding during this quarantine
i saw you know what time i leave my
house i follow you on patreon
8 15. 8 15 a.m
do you know why i do that there's a
reason why because there's nobody out
yeah i go against the grain
like i don't let cars behind me
i go against cars you got something to
say you shut your [ __ ] mouth yeah
i wear a hooded sweatshirt with a 22
just in case
jesus don't tell people that i don't
wear headphones
i put my mask on like a decent [ __ ]
american
and i take that [ __ ] bike from uh to
hunger
to [ __ ] uh toluca lake
i don't sometimes i go on the sidewalk
whatever
but trust me i know that i'm in danger
getting hit
every time i get on those bikes i say a
prayer because there's a lot of
[ __ ] texting i see it
you when you're on a bike you got to
work hard now
a scooter you're in danger you're in
danger your best bet is to get a bike
and go on the chandler trail that that's
what normal people would do
you're pretty safe there you know i've
done that a lot too
but the chandler trail is kind of weird
there's people walking
right yeah you know and there's people
with [ __ ] dogs they're gonna take
their dogs everywhere
can people leave the [ __ ] dogs at
home in california
you're gonna you your dad was hungry i
went to eat now austin
the lady sitting there with a [ __ ]
dog social distancing
the dog can't stay home not one day
everybody in california gotta [ __ ]
take a dog they have a motivation
[ __ ] leash emotional dogs
take xanax like everybody else do a line
of [ __ ] coke
waving coke is up to 1800 an ounce is it
really really
1800 an ounce what did it used to be six
they were giving it away three years ago
what happened
oh it's hard to get in coven and they
got an extra 600 a week in unemployment
what did you see that new mexican tunnel
they just found oh yeah the most
complicated tunnel they've ever
discovered that's an easy one they gave
them that one [ __ ]
remember they built 20 at a time yeah
yeah and they want you to find it they
a big victory you're jumping up and down
mexicans
stopped at the border the most
sophisticated tunnel in u.s
history discovered between mexico and
arizona
although it's not exactly clear what the
structure was intended for
it had ventilation a rail system and
extensive reinforcement
yeah look at that [ __ ] dude that's how
the vampires come in
that's how they got el chapo out you
ever see that the el chapo one's amazing
el chapo goes to take a [ __ ] and never
returns he goes behind this little thing
he's the only thing that keeps the
camera from seeing him taking a [ __ ] is
a thing
where he can't see him when he's sitting
so it's like a thing about this high
so he turns around towards where the
toilet is ducks down and disappears
forever from sight
like he's like taking a [ __ ] for like
five hours to go in and check on the guy
they find out there's a door behind the
[ __ ] and he's got a tunnel built in
there with a rail system
like a real rail system and lighting and
electricity goes a mile long
so he gets under the tunnel he gets in
there
they take him off before the [ __ ]
people in the jail can realize he's gone
he's a mile away he pops out of this
building
he gets out of this building and they
swoop him up in a truck or whatever
a helicopter and they they get them the
[ __ ] out of there but it's hilarious
watch
he goes behind this thing to take a [ __ ]
he's like this is like take a [ __ ] area
and when he does it he just disappears
so here's his take of [ __ ] area he's
like hmm
i'm just going to take my pants off real
quick let me lean forward
[Music]
duck's down boom he's through the floor
he's gone [ __ ] trouble bro they had
it
they had it all set up for him they
popped him out in the other end
his son got arrested recently and then
they released him
like [ __ ] it they got surrounded by
cartel people they negotiated and they
just released him
it was crazy that's a completely
different world it's a different world
it's right there bro you can walk there
if you live in the la jolla
you can walk there son how crazy
yeah crazy pretty let me tell you
something
there he is hey what's up guys
everything's cool good luck the [ __ ]
gonna let him go the [ __ ] uh
the uh pablo escobar two seasons
amazing we're very good that guy who
plays escobar is incredible the guy
what's his name i don't know he's uh
panamanian whatever
is he panamanian jamie's going to pull
it up that guy needs his respect
then you're so good then you have the
season of the
cali cartel yeah i i didn't make it
that one was too many that was murders
yet
that one opens up with them buried being
a guy wagner mora i think he's from
brazil
yeah brazilian we're sorry he got caught
he got tormented because the spanish was
bad
[ __ ] people could the guy could act
his ass oh he could access but then you
had season
the cali cartel that was good the season
opened up when
they rip a guy apart with motorcycles
they put a
motorcycle on each leg and they just
tear them apart that's the season opener
so you know it and the guy is gay that
runs
the click so he goes to that party gets
a bottle
[ __ ] takes over the dance floor makes
out with his gay lover
takes the bottle breaks it over the
guy's head then ties him up
with a motorcycle and rips him apart
[ __ ] tremendous opening
okay god then we skipped the couch this
is season three and four or season three
is the cali cartel
then it goes into season
uh narcos mexico and to me
in my world and you know me dawg i come
at you with lawrence fishburn
i'll tell you who's really doing that
craft right who are pimps of the game
right now that we've seen
who are the major pimps of the [ __ ]
game right now the major pimps of the
game
that you and i have seen in our lifetime
have been guys like lawrence fishburne
you know this kid who does john wick is
doing a great [ __ ] job
the english guy is the real deal daniel
say what you want about mine
which one she's amazing say what you
want no the other english dude
the one that was in the fighter the play
the one uh
ah you see capone you want to shoot
yourself in the head two times
leave me alone with tom hardy tom hardy
was good with gandalfini
that's the best thing [ __ ] tom hardy
did that and the [ __ ] bronsons
what christian bale is [ __ ] the real
deal you gotta rock with christian bale
but the dude who [ __ ] does
narcos mexico the little dude
that dude is on a different level
he's on a different level he takes that
show to a different level
you can't take your eyes off him and i
didn't even know that this latin
theater existed when i was a kid i
watched telemundo
and telenovelas that's the gay one he's
tremendous
that's the gay one that's the sick
that's when they're in cali cartel
this is all good stuff
but the guy narcos mexico
he's so [ __ ] good it's scary
how good he is he does two seasons
he's the one that that one and i saw he
tells the story of
what happened in new york we were brown
we were
buying brown weed and all of a sudden
they were selling a wheat called since
emilia
and it was a weed that was grown with no
seeds
so it was easier to pack and easier to
smuggle
so they had to convince these people
that this was the future
but there's a problem with sensomia it
has to be grown in the desert it can't
be grown anywhere else
because a male plant will [ __ ] up the
whole thing
so it's got to be grown in the desert
who grows weed in the desert
these [ __ ] set up an irrigation
thing explain the male
female plant thing i don't you know i
don't know not now but jamie
when he gets a minute when jason i know
it i know it's a thing like
hermaphrodites or something
they can't switch but yeah they they can
switch genders but the flowery ones are
the females
right like marijuana you want to make
sure that they're female and you
make sure the males don't [ __ ] them over
and switch them yeah i don't know how
to get too close and change each other
can you see the biggest
crop seeds from narcos i mean so
marijuana grows
transphobic these [ __ ]
mint seeds are actually look at the size
of this
[ __ ] this went on for days where they
just grew this weed
and they would do it right before do you
know how to grow weed
no every time i do it i fail
but this they show you how damn
they show you how look at that look at
the size of those
guys how did netflix pull this off what
do they do it's brilliant do you think
that's all cgi
a lot of cgi mixed with fake some plants
like some real
you can have real plants they're legal
now well they're probably just plastic
but this guy defines the system this guy
devised the system
that he knew that there was water in the
desert
and that's where they grew this weed
and the only this kid here he could eat
[ __ ] alive for breakfast with
his acting
that dude dad that little mexican right
there and i
watched him a couple times and i go
there's something special about this kid
i'm not gonna look him up or whatever
and i finally looked him up his mother
died when he was three
and his father was a stagehand in mexico
so his father was a set designer
which means that he grew up around his
father on the set designing
which made him a little bit more
creative than the average [ __ ] kid
he was also in star wars this kid will
eat [ __ ] up for lunch
he's gonna eat [ __ ] up for
lunch
when they let him go they just narcos
was his [ __ ]
he was that good diego luna that [ __ ]
good joe rogan
steals it and so he does even one
episode
when he tells his wife i don't need you
anymore
you could go whoa cold-blooded and how
he does it the whole
from a to z from a to z how he started
with weed first
and then he went on a mission to do a
favor and he saw cocaine
in nicaragua and he goes all the cocaine
is stuck in nicaragua
why is it sucking nicaragua because they
had closed the roots
from miami so he went uh
he went to [ __ ] cali cartel they told
them you got two choices
you got the cali cartel the legit
they don't even look like drug dealers
but then we got another guy
that's very emotional
so you have to pick who you want to go
with
he went with the businessman cut a deal
on the way to the airport they get
kidnapped
they take them right to pablo's house oh
jesus it is one of the greatest [ __ ]
scenes
ever when how pablo talks to him he says
what did you are you doing here i went
to cali
pablo lights up a [ __ ] joint pablo
was talking to him he went to cali okay
he go and then he goes what are you
gonna do with a hippopotamus pablo had a
hippopotamus
pablo's telling him like he loves
hippopotamuses because they're smooth
and all this [ __ ]
the whole time he's just smoking a joint
because i'm gonna cut your deal
for every load you take of this you take
one of mine in
and that's how that whole thing goes oh
the guy agreed to it so and the guy
agreed smart yeah agreed
to reload because don't be greedy [ __ ]
he goes because if you do that for me
then you're gonna put me out of business
do you think that narcos is like the
rocky movies for drug dealers
like this it's very sad you know what
narcos the first two
the first two seasons the first two
seasons or three seasons of narcos
is very sad for a guy like me really
because it shows you the truth of what
happened
it shows you that the colombians had
something going on and once the
americans saw the amount of money
they tapped right into it right that
whole thing with barry seal
and arkansas and that's all real we
can't rewrite that it's like
the first time you realized that kennedy
hit was done by the c.i.a
or whoever did it right you said to
yourself wow we have a government that
isis their own people right
now they [ __ ] help bring in these
drugs the same war on drugs that they
have on paper
they're profiting off and then when you
look at the [ __ ] weed thing
from the narcos perspective it was
you you don't know the amounts of weed
they were bringing in
they were supplying the whole country
with green weed
the whole country would censor me
damn and everybody was in on it
but meanwhile reagan is on there with
his wife
just saying no yeah so
you see the hypocrisy and it kind of
hurts you you go what the [ __ ] else
won't they do you know well the just
saying no thing
was coming from the same administration
that funded the
the conscience versus the sandinistas
with cia drug money
run through south central l.a they show
him through freeway ricky ross
who's been on the podcast twice yes they
show him the real
frogs yeah they show narcos the mexican
kid i just told you
they show him going because the plane
goes down he's in them how they
discovered that whole thing was
a plane goes down ah and all of a sudden
oliver wood whatever his name is oliver
north
oliver south whatever your [ __ ] name
was over north
well guess what happened narco
went to the c.i.a after they had killed
kiki camarena
he's the most wanted man in the [ __ ]
world
for being one of the guys that murdered
kiki camarena
he shows up at ca headquarters and goes
whoa whoa i got the [ __ ]
i got the [ __ ] answer to your
problems what year was this jamie
i will continue to bring you [ __ ]
weapons this has happened a couple of
times
2007. i think there's a this is a later
one this is one that you and i brought
up before because it was like a cia
also of course it is they [ __ ] crash
all the time
there was one that just happened didn't
one just happen somewhere in the world
they glued them up with cocaine as [ __ ]
they get greedy
when you get cooked up you're like it's
going to make it jesus wants us to land
just mexico i looked at bikes but there
was one that just happened like real
real recently
in afghanistan there's one that happened
no that was 2007. there's one that
happened like a week ago
no there was uh well it wasn't a cia
plane that landed recently but it was
one that crashed right after taking off
yeah there it is it was in new zealand
right or uh
australia melbourne australia melbourne
there you go there's not as much it's a
half a ton
they had one of them old [ __ ]
propeller planes loaded up with coke
don't play into the world you have to
you have to be honest about what you
weigh
like if you get on the if you're getting
playing with your wife and she's like
146 you're like pitch
i don't want to die i used to have to be
152. my mom would make extra money on
the side when she worked at wendy's
and take those planes down to like
atlanta
and drop off stuff and uh i just
remember being a kid in the back seat
reading garfield going i'm going to die
like i'm going to die how many times did
you have to fly
i'd probably say at least 10 times that
i remember oh my god
oh my god i get sick in those little
places i did one of those [ __ ]
what was wendy's dropping off like
special sauce
yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah man no that was an interesting cast
that narcos is an interesting they did
they did them right
i think this year they're going to miami
they killed it with pablo they killed it
killed it
killed it that guy's so good killed it
and the guy
the guy i like that they hired was that
dude that got like 2 000 years in jail
the one who ran the island like his
story is
hilarious because he was uh
a john lennon fanatic yeah and
he was half german so he was a hitler
but he was spanish okay and he was
it sounds like a saturday livestream so
when the cops went when the
feds went all uh extradite
on these guys they became the
extraditables
this guy took to the radio and they show
scenes of him
on the radio [ __ ] ah like
okay so you cannot take us back to the
united states
because you're the number one exporter
of our product and he's snowing awesome
he sees like an assistant walk by he
goes hey
come here and all of a sudden he's like
and listen she just kneels down
she's blowing him on camera and he's and
he's like
listen to me you have to he became nuts
when was this listen listen to what they
did okay hold on is there a video this
you can get
oh my god carlos laid there is
a [ __ ] lunatic carlos laid there
was the one who went to pablo
and said i'm gonna i'm gonna fly the
coke back for you
but we're gonna make a stop on an island
so they bought an island
they [ __ ] threw the doctor off there
was a white doctor
nice to meet you and they were like
listen
there's a whole story about this
hysterical the guy called the feds
there's something going on over there
they're doing pornographic
you know they're running in planes of
blow wow and this is one they bought
everybody out but there was this one
white dude who's like
this is my island i'm an american i
fought in world war two i'm not leaving
and they're like dog
we're gonna [ __ ] kill you okay we're
gonna keep
and all night they would bring it in
planes refueling them
and sending them out carlos laid there
what does it say u.s drug lord and
escobar partner laid there
released for in germany from prison when
was this oh my god he's
just now from florida to germany oh from
florida to germany because he's
originally from germany he's his father
was german he's got 2 000 years
so what they did was this what they did
was this it doesn't take a [ __ ]
genius
this kid got the island he made them a
bunch of money
but then he started doing a podcast from
the island
with cameras and naked women what of him
snorting coke with a robot how old was
he
who the [ __ ] knows 28 30 just making
20 million a day i think if you're
making 20 million a day
and you're just addicted to coke there's
bags of blow behind you
he's just ripping bags open snorting
them just talking he was a john lennon
fan
so he would talk about coming today is
he would do these videos for hours for
days
so he was like an original youtube star
yeah so what they did was but he wasn't
posting on youtube
he was like he did so what they did was
myspace boy he's the first one they gave
up
when the [ __ ] got deep and the
colombians were in trouble
the five colombians sat down they said
listen this kid's on an island talking
about jim morrison in the doors
let's let him let's let the feds know
where he's at
we'll give him you and we got no beef
so they actually died and laid there
they gave him
two thousand years oh my god look up the
sentence i'm not trying to be funny
they gave him a thousand so why would
they extradite him to germany because he
gave them information years later about
he gave them he gave them like vital he
gave them
really great information that if the
country [ __ ] knew
we would sink like he gave him [ __ ]
he gave them information that he was he
also not beside having his
island that that was also a
a distraction his main contributor his
main
supplier was fidel so he
fidel was letting him go to cuba bring
the coke to cuba stock it and for every
ship that went out from cuba to the
united states
with a cuban flag fidel would get a
kickback of 800
000 fidel was sending three four ships a
day
so he testified against fidel which
obviously nobody ever arrested fidel and
he told them everything he knew about
the ins and outs of money moving
you could find it online all the [ __ ] he
had done
this guy in blow is based off that guy
in blow is based on him
george young in prison isn't it funny
like no one wants their son
to do that but everybody loves these
movies
yeah that's weird isn't that weird you
know if you had a son
you know what i became a [ __ ] drug
dealer in this movie
his father is henry hill no [ __ ] and he
knows that he's doing it it's a very
good move is that real in real life no
no no no no no in the movie
oh so it's a fictional yoda ray leota
plays his father in this movie
oh henry hill you mean yeah yeah yeah
and one day
i thought you meant the actual henry
hill oh my god what are the odds it's a
criminal family right
translation thank you very much jamie
how to translate for you
jamie's a psychic jamie's 100 a psychic
it's really crazy to say that because
in the movie he goes to his house one
time the father
and he goes so all this on the landscape
is
what are you doing son you know and he
goes what are you talking about
she comes from wealth you know and then
he gets
busted and stuff look at this right here
look at that old-school corvette
look at that [ __ ] car look at his
house [ __ ] boston
he's in a palace look at that car though
go wide look at that [ __ ] car that's
a
generation one corvette that's sexy
that's even before my
mine is a 65 that's like probably early
early 60s maybe even 50s that thing's
amazing
those cars back then man you like that
early
first series corvette holy [ __ ] what a
car that is
ron white's got one of those a sick one
see if you can find it see if ron
white's
corvette is online ron white has a sick
corvette a guy let me go piss again you
get out of there big boy
um generation one he has a
uh generation one convertible that's
just immaculate
ron white has got to be one of the
coolest people on the planet sweetheart
gotta be one of the coolest people owns
his own tequila company
funny as [ __ ] always cool to hang with
never
never has an attitude he's never had an
attitude he's always
ron white you like you what you see is
what you get that's ron [ __ ]
white he's always
super sweet hugs people reminds me of
texas
in a human form he's [ __ ] awesome
he's just a [ __ ] awesome guy
i love him to death there's his car he's
got the the dopest choice in vehicles
look at that
god damn what a car is he having
somebody else drive it for him i think
it's probably like when he first got it
nascar driver kirk
oh wow look at that thing man
god damn that's pretty that's so pretty
america knew how to do [ __ ] back then
red band
i think it's getting more exciting now
honestly with cars i love it oh for sure
yeah new stuff for sure with cars cars
the most exciting now
are you going to get one of those uh
what's it called
cyber trucks no no no no the the gas the
ford bronco
no yeah i have a real bronco i have a
1972 bronco yeah
those are real i have mine's a manual it
doesn't even have good brakes
those there's a thing about broncos like
like those old broncos even mine like i
have a coyote engine in it it's like a
it's icon so uh jonathan ward makes it
it's a they take a uh
an eight-cylinder mustang engine like
for if you bought a mustang gt and they
put that in an old bronco and
tweak everything but it's still not
really fast it's not supposed to be fast
it's just supposed to be interesting
it's like you're driving this thing it's
like all mechanical and [ __ ]
but the new broncos not going to be like
that new bronco is going to be dope
no doubt about it but it's going to be a
different kind of dope it's going to be
like a modern dope what is that again
show me what we
put it's interesting uh larger cyber
truck will be north american ass kicker
smaller cyber truck highly likely and to
be sent to countries we hate
you know why right north american ass
kicker the the size of the cyber truck
like elon wanted to make it smaller
because it's
bigger than what a average sized garage
is single
car garage oh and so that's the problem
that's why there's probably going to be
a smaller one
that is a [ __ ] problem yeah we are
gross
we do need things to be as big as
humanly possible
if there's a [ __ ] xl diet coke i
always get it
i i'm like the regular large is not
enough i am
thirsty americans are greedy you know we
see a bigger truck if there's a
like like samsung has it nailed right
they sell you the regular note
and then you can get the note ultra
you've got a laptop in your pocket boy
have you got one of those folds did you
did you fall for the full the new phone
looks pretty badass
it does there's a new new one right it's
just coming out yeah what do i get next
guys
just keep with your iphone my phone the
thing about iphones is here's the thing
when you have the [ __ ] wait the new ones
when you try
the two different platforms the iphone
got way ahead of everybody with two
things one
airdrop airdrop's so important if you
make a funny video of something you see
something
oh my god send me that i get it
instantly bluetooth it's like
it's fast it's fast as [ __ ] yeah i'll
send like gigabyte files to my
girlfriend to edit and stuff like that
and it's like
like 15 seconds also when i send you
pictures
if they come through imessage they're
like they're better quality they're
better resolution
there's like a lot of things that you
get used to you get used to imessage
you get used to the fact you could
answer a message from your laptop if you
had a
mac laptop there's a lot of [ __ ]
also like buying things with uh will pay
yeah
apple pays this [ __ ] when you go to a
like a
supermarket i've been using that phone
the whole time look at yourself
do it on your pay for your groceries it
takes three seconds your watch can do it
too yeah
i just do you feel like you're in the
future i totally if i can pay for things
with my phone i feel like i'm in the
future i love it
and you're not touching [ __ ] and getting
corona correct i remember dana white
told me about that
in like 2005 like bro in japan their
phones they pay for [ __ ] with their
phones i was like what
like what like yeah they go through
things they pay for things with their
phones they're so far ahead of us
now here we are joey diaz what the [ __ ]
happened to you
don't i'm just thinking about i don't
like i don't like that much information
now
throw me that lighter like i don't like
that much information i wouldn't want to
keep
yeah but that's what you said when email
first came out or buying on amazon i
know my
voicemail voicemail remember when he
would get mad at you if you left a
[ __ ] voice don't you [ __ ] text
message me
okay nobody [ __ ] voice knows me you
know but the text messages
you would get so mad remember that he
still does kind of i just erase
if you touch me if you're still text
messaging me
like it depends what day but that's just
people i just
erase like i don't even look at the
message well if i don't recognize the
number
here's the problem the problem is you're
awesome
so there's a lot of people that want to
talk to you that's the problem and send
you cool pictures
no you want to talk to me if you know me
that well
you'll [ __ ] call me i don't want to
text with nobody
i feel like the thing that everybody
worries about is using their phone too
much
that's almost the number one thing
everybody worries about because if you
didn't worry about using your phone too
much you would say oh i just need
something i can text with and answer
emails
and occasionally look up something on
google right that's it
but you're addicted to your goddamn
phone so you're going to be
instagramming and
snapchatting i'm tick-tocking none of
that [ __ ]
you know tick-tock [ __ ] no it's against
the law [ __ ]
[ __ ]
joe you should tick-tock you're missing
a whole corner of your market do you
tick-tock
don't i no i've never take that okay but
i'm saying you should tick-tock
listen i'm just a manager here my first
tick-tock video i'm not
i'm just i'm not trying to play
quarterback i'm trying to manage this
team joey
tick-tock tock no with [ __ ] let me
tell you something
this is there was a moment in the main
room i don't know if you remember this
but this was like many years ago we're
talking about like
2001 maybe maybe around then maybe 2
000 there was no one in the main room
you're on stage
and you had danny play black sabbath war
pig
i took my shirt do you remember that
yeah do you remember you had danny play
war pig and you took your shirt off 15
[ __ ] years ago and you were singing
into the microphone
and we were like yes because it was
it was there was no audience no there
was 10 people yeah there was 10 people
but there was also 10 comedians
so there was 20 people in the audience
in the main room 10 of them were just
audience members
and then joey's on stage he gets the
spotlight on him and
he's [ __ ] singing it not just like
not lip-syncing
he's [ __ ] singing at the top of his
lungs to war
pigs and we're we're all like yes
it was what the comedy store is it was
the madness
it was sink or swim it was chaos it was
there's 10 people the audience what are
you gonna do
jose diaz what are you gonna do you took
your [ __ ] shirt off
and you started singing into the
microphone full clip
and we were cheering the audience was
cheering because we recognized that you
did something fun
you did something special you took a
moment a [ __ ] 12
45 spot in the main room on whatever
night it was i don't remember it was
only weekends
back in those days the main room was
only open on weekends so it happened
today
fridays and saturdays yeah so it had to
be it was most likely friday or saturday
but it was late everybody was gone and
you just took control of this moment in
this way that i never i'm never gonna
forget
because it was positive it was it was
exciting and it made me realize what
part of what live comedy is it's it's
not just like
set up punchline it's not there's
moments where you capture these moments
since you just knew how to
you know how to grab a hold of that
[ __ ] wave and
ride it you were just hating that wave
of love you were just riding it
i've been obsessed especially when i
started watching youtube
why youtube got into comedy and i
followed
comedy but then i looked at it
differently
when youtube hit i started studying
singers i started studying singers
to really learn how to really get
my message across so i started with
robert plant
nobody gets the message across like
when he's singing since i've been loving
you okay you have to study the great
singers
i studied the singer from bad company
his body movements then i studied the
singer from
leonard skinner so i copied i stole
leonard skynyrd's that dude whatever his
name was when you see joey diaz on stage
i'm just faking it i stole
leonard skynyrd singer's persona
on stage the persona is that walk
that he makes in oakland in the 77
the walk of james brown onto africa
with the cape which they took the cape
off
me and you laughed about it yes yes once
you
take that side of music and you mix it
with what we're trying to do
and implement it at the comedy store is
when your life really explodes as a
comedian
that just dennison touched into it this
little thing you touched into it yes
look at him that show's amazing he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
you don't you cannot give a [ __ ] so i
studied what
you know just a couple of singers have
this joe rogan
that you could tell what they're singing
about by looking at their body
robert plant since i've been loving you
live from the garden
is [ __ ] body language
is superb but nobody's body language
was better on stage than [ __ ] robert
plant
mick jagger did his thing but
selling you what three guys behind you
are playing
is a gift that i also wanted to tap into
that's why i kind of liked josh's idea
if you didn't do it you missed out as a
comic
can you imagine what would happen if i
said no to it for months and i did it
it was the worst anxiety attack i ever
got
but it was worth doing it one time john
rogan what were you going to say i'm
sorry
no you imagine if leonard skinner didn't
crash in that plane
we would have had a complete different
world today the outlaws would have been
huge
because leonard skinner was already
blowing ted nugent out of the water on
tour on that tour
it was well known those those songs were
so good
i know a little i know a little about
love maybe i can guess the rest
you have no idea you have no idea dude
to this day man
when i do my kickboxing boxing workouts
nine out of ten times
i put on a leonard skinner it gets you
angry yeah i put it on the playlist yeah
yeah but it's just it's just they
weren't supposed to be that good
they're from florida for real they're
not supposed that that's the story of
leonard skynyrd they're not supposed to
be that good ronnie vanzant all those
guys they're from
florida they were powerful bro in a way
in a weird way
in a weird way they would rehearse their
rifts right
like eddie bravo was explaining to me
like the the difference in like some
like some people
have riffs where they just go off like
some guys just shred
and some guys have riffs where the whole
riff is like this
really calculated solo
it's not as simple as like a guy just
[ __ ] wow
for the crowd now this guy's got a whole
like
when they did like if they did uh
free bird they that that one guitar solo
might be the greatest guitar solo of all
time
it was so polished because it's a crazy
solo
because they they did that solo over and
over and over and over and over again
[ __ ] it was good man when he hits the
leap when he leaps in the air
and slams down on the good side here
[ __ ] [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
look at them but you know who else had
the flavor of the almond brothers
[ __ ] yeah
but this here is beautiful i study this
i study him
look at him he's not even he just spit
he just [ __ ] spit
joey every time i used to have to do uh
kevin and bean
i would do kevin and bean a lot they
were the only like la radio station that
i would do
i'd you'd have to get up really early in
the morning if you want to get there by
seven so i'd have to leave my house like
five in the morning so it was like
[ __ ] dark out right
and i would smoke a joint in my driveway
and i would play midnight rider
i'd play the allman brothers midnight
rider [ __ ]
yeah i got to see almond brothers a few
times did you really
where uh columbus ohio god damn
what were they doing they used to do a
tour with i believe
uh like blues traveler or somebody like
that there was a few of those jam band
type
bands i forget what the tour used to be
called hmm
dude we had uh rob lowe here on the
other day
i saw that i didn't watch the whole
podcast it was amazing but it made me
stop and think about some of the [ __ ]
that i forgot that was awesome
you know when you're hanging out with
someone like rob lowe you start thinking
about other [ __ ] that was awesome back
when you know you first found out about
him
yeah he's amazing he's a nice [ __ ]
guy
austin powers yes he's a but he's like a
really nice guy in real life like you
meet him like
he's everything you would hope he'd be
he's like really charming really smart
he's good on instagram too like his live
little videos and stuff he makes
he's super legit he's a good guy like a
really nice guy i'm happy to know him
it was fun talking to him but at a
certain point in time when you're
talking to someone that's that famous it
does weird you out
you're like you're robbed low like this
is so weird
you just feel so strange
so i said dawg we're leaving yeah i
think we have to
this is the thing is bravo staying i
don't know
he'll come well i'll get out of here
there there's a the tax thing there's
the crime thing there's the looting
thing
there's a no no ability to work for too
many people things old school
restriction queso the restrictions
the barbecue this shout out to hogly
woggies in van nuys though
you rated hogley blog yeah they can hang
you with anybody on the planet i don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says i've eaten
amazing barbecue in austin in houston
dallas and
nashville they have great barbecue don't
get me wrong but hogly woglies and van
nuys can hang
with all them [ __ ] people just don't
know that's an old-school joint that
plays been around forever next to that
nasty strip club
they shoot a movie there one night i was
so [ __ ] embarrassed about there's a
bunch of nasty strippers
one night what's up with you why you
giving me weird looks all night today
well you don't love me no more
what no i was just thinking of
barbecuing strip clubs oh okay
you know what they're doing now because
the massage parts and everything's
closed and
strip clubs and stuff they're having
airbnb sex parties i guess that's the
new thing
right that's where the [ __ ] spike's
coming from
i thought about you two weeks ago when i
went to cvs
and i saw a white guy and a hot
african-american chick having an
argument outside of cvs
at 9 20 in the morning he was a little
chubby
and they were having some type of loud
discussion i went and i got my
medication when i walked out
he's yelling that i want my wallet back
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why'd you think of me because
because i'm like talking about all those
dirty [ __ ]
and [ __ ] so this is how bad it is why i
live now
so this is my cvs this is the main one
i've been going to
for 10 years and also when i walk out
i walk towards my car but i hear him go
i want my [ __ ] wallet back you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and she's like i didn't take your wallet
and what are you gonna do call the
police
and tell them what i sucked your dick is
that not a wedding ring around your hand
and he goes [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] if
it's a wedding ring give me my [ __ ]
wallet and he hauls off and smacks the
dexa like [ __ ]
name a knockout in the ufc this is way
better than anything you've ever seen
the [ __ ] pimp was down the block he
took off on his [ __ ] car
the wallet fell out of her bra people
ran to him
me i didn't have a piece so i got in my
car and took off because
i was shooting in north hollywood lately
two days [ __ ] later
i'm at the office i go let me go check
on the office get some [ __ ] out of there
i go down the block i go down [ __ ]
whatever and i hook on lancashire
i'm stuck by the train station i'm the
third car
in uh the inside lane
so i'm going south down lankersham
okay i'm about to hit magnolia the
federal
all that stuff but i'm sitting right
there crossing the train station
and all of a sudden out of the left of
my eye
i see this commotion and i see this
woman looking up
and all of a sudden i see an axe handle
or something hit her
and she goes down into the street and
it's a white guy
with a vest on just hitting people with
axe handles
and they're going down one by one all of
a sudden
i see a chubby guy running across the
street
and [ __ ] he starts chasing the chubby
guy traffic is beeping
beep beep beep it's 3 30 in the
afternoon and also i go this is my
chance to be a [ __ ] hero
i hook a u-turn and i'm going to shoot
down the street
and catch him at the end and hit him
with my car it's been years
since i hit a [ __ ] with my car
when i get to the corner i hit the
[ __ ] left
the guy sees me he dropped the axe
handle already
he sees me and he runs left instead of
right if he would have ran
right i would have just hit him with the
car and kept going it would have been an
accident
i didn't see him he committed a crime he
dropped the axe handle and the guy was
on the floor
and his head was bleeding and then the
guy ran back to the train station
to get some more what is happening
that's why i'm leaving
[ __ ] lancashire man is [ __ ] nuts
my girl calls me my my dog she's married
she's my buddy she's like i had a rough
day on the set can i talk to you i'll
meet you behind the y like i usually
meet you
let's smoke a number we socially
distance
she sits in her car and i sit in my car
and she tells me about a day on the set
and it's ten after nine because i gotta
catch it before mercy goes to sleep
so i mean like a quarter to nine we're
talking and also when you hear
bah
right behind them we're like did you
[ __ ] hear that that was right on the
[ __ ] corner
i go home my wife goes thank god you're
home
she goes it's all over the place there
was a shooting at magnolia lancashire
she goes to drive by and then the guy
they shot at shot twice
that chicken place is there there's a
chicken place i said hot chicken
hot chicken hot dave's hot chicken yeah
dog it's not bueno by me though
it's not blaming it by a lot of people
so the the axe handle just came out of
nowhere and hit this lady in the head i
was sitting there
in my own business this guy came outside
so it stopped bueno you're seeing more i
see i went i go to burbank a lot and i
go down magnolia they've been saying
that about new york too random people
get sucker punched
new york and chicago are both really bad
right now
valley village park a guy was walking
this dog at two in the morning four
identified men jumped out of a car and
threw a beating on him
you know for no reason
i don't want what's in seattle and
portland to come down here and catch
my wife had to go downtown the idea to
send money
and she goes downtown it's just horrible
it's already
horrible to begin with but it's it's
nightmare now you have stayed up here
and up there
your final conclusion is to get in the
car one day next week i've told you
and just go say your goodbyes to the
calm you start by yourself you don't
have to bring nobody
put your hand on the wall make a left
only sienna
and then pick a street and make a left
so you can make another left to get on
the one-on-one
and make a mental projection of when
this will come back
but you know what everybody wanted the
zombie apocalypse
you got it [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you want everybody ha ha ha ha
zombie it's pretty close
well everybody wanted society to burn so
so many people wanted society to burn
i just don't think they expected it to
burn this way they just didn't want
the current system to be in place they
wanted a more equitable system
but this is uh this is what happens when
there's a breakdown when it's a
breakdown we go back to who we were
just a few thousand years ago like this
is why it's so important for
civilization to be maintained it's not
just because
you know it uh it helps rich people
protect their money and helps people
feel safe
it helps everybody grow you're in a bad
state if you've got violence everywhere
because people can adapt
to whatever state they're in if they
just get become accustomed to having
violence all the time everywhere
is going to be a much more dangerous
place with the same people
same people living in it and two years
later it's a far more dangerous place
that's for whatever reason whatever
causes people to lean one way or another
like that that's not a good sign
that's a sign of a very shaky
civilization and i think that uh
we can lean one way or the other here we
could either lean
to where we fight more and was more
violence more chaos more destruction
more people angry
or if we can calm the [ __ ] down and
figure out a way to
work through [ __ ] together as human
beings we're the same people that
lived in this this this planet two years
ago when everything was amazing
with the same people yeah there was
always problems on this planet
but when here you are two years later
it's the same human beings
we're just confronted with a problem we
didn't expect and we didn't do a good
job hitting it
we [ __ ] it up and we we have to figure
out how to do it right
but we have to also figure out how to
maintain the goddamn economy
you have to have both you can't just
have one thing you have to figure out a
way where people can work for safe in a
safe way
it's possible it's got to be possible
what would you do different than
garcinia
gavin i'm a [ __ ] what would you do i'm
not the guy that you would come to
that's going to tell you how to run a
city but i would say you have to realize
there's a ratio and there's a ratio of
like if people hit a certain amount of
poverty
and despair they will covet
if they hit a certain amount of despair
and unemployment
there's a there's a statistic you could
actually find out like
they've done studies you you see it's a
correlation between the amount of
suicides
the amount of drug addicts the amount of
people who commit crime
they're all connected people have no
choice they have no way out
and that's what a lot of that this is so
we had they look they focused on one
kind of life
loss and that's the life loss loss of
the disease but they didn't focus on the
life loss
loss to the economy collapsing or to
people
being able unable to pay for their bills
and get depressed or suicidal or drug
addicts
they didn't factor that too you have to
factor all that [ __ ] in
they didn't do that they only factored
the one thing which was you don't want
people to die of the disease
how do we make sure that the hospitals
aren't overstaffed how how do we make
sure that people can get or overloaded
rather how do we make sure that
people can work safely and they didn't
do a good job of that
but nobody did nobody in america did
they never were prepared for something
they weren't prepared they had no idea
how could they we were not prepared
and that's why you can't point a finger
at anybody and i'm not apologizing for
them either
because there's probably somebody like
bill gates or something like that who
saw it coming
a while ago and he would have done a
much better job of if you put him in
charge of setting something like that
that up and protecting people from
pandemics and this is how much money you
need to hit any sort of problem
if it happens if you don't you're not
going to be able to contain it if you
don't contain it it's going to spread
you're like this is an investment you
have to make if you like laid it out to
people in that way
who [ __ ] knows man that [ __ ] might
work it might have worked
they might have been able to if not
prevent this maybe slow it down
but even new zealand just has new cases
new zealand had no cases for a hundred
days
and now they have cases really i thought
i just read they didn't i believe it's
today
i believe today they found some new
cases still
this [ __ ] is crazy contagious it's crazy
contagious
it's weird
well you know what [ __ ] four new cases
shout out to dana white for the bubble
on one house i guess he came
up with this [ __ ] how did he get him on
it
no i don't think football is gonna work
it's crazy and that's gonna devastate
whoever would have saw this coming seven
months ago nobody
nobody saw this coming crazy nobody just
was so
tense have you noticed everyone's so
tense it's a huge reset though it might
i mean it's going to be interesting to
see what's on the other side of this
you know reset it might be put more
positive it might be not
but i i feel like
whenever things are really bad like you
know with riots or with
looting or with craziness i feel like at
the end
the other end of it people usually take
a deep breath
and they try to figure out okay what's
the solution it's getting through the
crazy part where people want to smash
windows and burn things and
you get if we can get through that and
get to the point where
rational people from both sides are
talking the problem is
a lot of other people have jumped in
that aren't rational and they want it
all to burn down
and you know their life's not so great
anyway so they'd be happy to set this
federal building on fire [ __ ] you my dad
hates me [ __ ] you
you know there's a lot of that out there
you got to be real careful with
like who you give a license to light a
building on fire
like who are they doing it on behalf is
that the wisest way to handle our
resources
would it be better if we just like
chanted sang songs
maybe like uh stated our argument no
somebody
so many people want to light things on
fire why because they become a part of
any
like if you have a if you have like a
legitimate cause it's a really good
cause but a bunch of idiots jump in
and they start [ __ ] it up like that's
what happens with people
if you just have a cause where anybody
can join and it's one of the most
pivotal things
it's on the news every day and everyone
every day
is fixated on it of course you're going
to get attention [ __ ] in there
there's a tension horse in every single
walk of life
you're going to get attention wars as
activists there's going to be some
activists that ruin it for all the other
ones
the other ones that were out there
really just want things to change
they're really tired of people getting
shot by cops they're really tired of
injustice they really are and then
there's people that are crazy
they want to hit people with bike locks
light buildings on fire they're there
too
that's a problem the problem is we're
all individuals
whenever we jump into groups like that
based on some sort of ideology
there's gonna be people on your team
that you're not gonna agree with you're
stuck with their decisions you're stuck
with what they do
and then everybody digs their [ __ ]
heels in everybody wants to be either
left wing or right way
you're the winners are against us you're
red or blue come on son
it's it's like message board 101. it's
dumb
there's always a couple people you're
like all right it's dumb
there should be no president there
should be a bunch of people that are in
charge of different jobs
it should be like the president of
finance the president of war
the president of agriculture the
president of the environment someone who
only knows that one discipline
do you think trump really has any idea
what the [ __ ] they're doing when they're
fracking
do you think he's paying attention to
what happens in people's water wells
they're like their toilet bowl is on
fire no one knows why
come on man can you imagine if you lived
in one of those fracking places and you
took a [ __ ] and it was awful
so you lit a match and you threw it into
your bowl hoping you know you would like
kill some of the smell of your horrible
[ __ ]
and then the match hits the [ __ ] bowl
and lights on fire because your water's
flammable
because they're fracking that's real
that's totally possible
do you think trump knows about that
there's no way he knows about that he's
got a hundred different hotels with his
name on them
they have giant gold letters like that's
what i like that's what i'm looking for
he's not paying attention to what's
happened to people that are fracking he
has
no interest no one can you can only
think of so many things man
is fracking what caused that earthquake
in north carolina
it's causing earthquakes everywhere the
number of earthquakes
since fracking let's let's before i talk
[ __ ] what's the [ __ ] use bro
science fracking let's find out it's
what percentage of um
increase in earthquake activity what is
it
drilling for oil pretty much right yeah
yeah yeah it's basically they're
drilling into it's a more complicated
way of drilling but through this
they've liberated so much oil that we're
not as dependent on if we aren't
dependent anymore
on international oil they've been able
to suck a lot of it out of the ground
but for people that live there
it's horrific there's a guy named is it
josh fox who has that book gasland
or a documentary gas land i believe
that's his name
uh he he he's been on here before about
it which
this is from inside science for maybe a
year what does that say there were you
highlighted
i didn't highlight it's just weirdly
highlighted already even in western
canada
only about one in 300 fracking
operations causes earthquakes oh no big
deal
300 large enough for a person to feel in
north america at the moment
imagine how funny that is hey man
seriously we only cause
one earthquake for every 300.
we're changing the earth only one out of
three they don't tell you how many
fracking operations they have
what if they have like 300 a day across
3 000 different holes in the ground
which seems like that makes actual sense
it's probably something high like that
yeah dude you know people have these
ranches
out in these places and then they they
have these things set up on these
ranches where they'll
they'll frack and dig into the ground
and good luck if you have like a water
source that's connected to that
apparently
and sometimes the gas gets out of the
ground it [ __ ] up the air quality and
bro that gets dark they aren't just
small quakes
although fracturing related earthquakes
are chronic
they were thought to be minor but new
research is showing they could be quite
large and damaging
the focus of the study of a 5.7
magnitude quake near
prague oklahoma damaged 14 homes
and other structures in the area imagine
you're in prague
oklahoma you're like at least i can just
sit on the porch and relax
we're away from most folks
and these fracking [ __ ] they
chewed up the ground
under your house like the government has
to decide like how deep
under your house is this still your
house like if you buy a
pot of land and they drink your
milkshake
you remember that from that movie let
there be blood he's like i drank your
milkshake
do you remember that you remember what
i'm talking about
dude do you remember
dog why am i gonna see you again you're
gonna see me anytime you want all right
anytime let's make scheduled times when
we see each other
you're going to do a comedy club down in
a podcast most likely
i'm definitely going to do a podcast
most likely i'm going to do a comedy
club there too
why not be fun for all of us what are
you going to do you're going to have
your first winner and you're going to be
like why the [ __ ] am i here
exactly this is daniel day lewis
explaining to this guy
how he drinks his milkshake he's
explaining to this guy how he puts his
pipes
underneath this dude's land and he
drinks his milkshake and
nothing you could do about it it's like
it's weird there's a num
you know i don't know how far under your
house
i paid him ten thousand dollars cash you
can't play it
you've got that motion plus [ __ ] still
on your your tvs guys that
setting that makes it look like a a soap
opera does it
yeah both of your tvs have that where it
stabilizes
the shake of a natural camera so now it
looks like a soap opera
youtube on youtube uh no your tv
settings on both of these tvs have
your motion plus uh turned on do you
notice that
no watch videos yeah it looks normal to
me
really it looks like a soap opera to you
yeah the it's like got that creepy look
where it
looks like there's no jiggle in the
camera and everyone it's like there's
just tripods everywhere
really yeah i would have never noticed
i didn't point it out i know what you're
talking about but i don't see it oh i
see it huh
interesting hate it so much that is the
nerdiest video talking ever
it's one of the worst things ever man it
drives me crazy i hate it so i don't
even notice it
it's like you know how most tv shows
have like a little like
like you're holding a camera like a
realistic kind of like breathing of uh
of somebody filming it right when the
motion plus
fixes all that it makes it so it looks
like it's just on a tripod and somebody
hit record in the recording somebody
sitting there it's called the
soap opera effect uh so it just looks
like a cheap camera
most tvs have it turned on to begin with
because tv companies think that looks
better and people want that but when i
see it
i i i i get [ __ ] that's so panicky
i've never even heard of that or i mean
i have heard of it
but i never thought of it auto motion
plus is a motion smoothing feature that
eliminates ghosting and blurring
that occurs from fast moving images this
looks great on live tv like sporting
events or parades which are filmed at 30
frames per second
that's from samsung saying that maybe
it's just better for sports though
maybe it actually is better for sports i
mean because most sports are not
handheld you know it's like overhead
stuff
but it doesn't does it affect like how
it looks when things are moving fast
like if people are sprinting or
something probably because it's it's
it's it's not there's no jiggle to it
you know but it already doesn't have
jiggle to begin with so it's
sure so would it be better to do it that
way with movies
but the way with the emotions [ __ ] with
like fights and things like that
fights probably not but like football
and baseball or
something like that something that's
stationary cameras for the most part
i didn't know that you know that
kid's goddamn video no let me ask you
something ask me you calling the fights
this week
yes i am all right i'm very excited
vegas yeah the bubble yeah i this is a
crazy
fight man the trilogy daniel cormier is
deep in miocic
so you get tested friday and then why i
got tested today
is that curtis and i'm going to get
tested again uh probably like
i'll test myself on thursday too
a shitload of vitamins i don't want to i
don't want to make it
yeah hitting that sauna keeping away
from people wearing a mask
uh that's a big fight man it's a real
big fight and when you get those hot
sauna things do you have somebody
babysitting in the outside you just be
like hey
check on me every 10 minutes i might
what because are you scared of passing
out or something like that
is that a thing who are you talking no
all right who are you talking to
that's what i worry about my will is too
strong you'll be hallucinating next
thing you're going to wake up you're
going to be bacon
no it's not that bad dude 180 degrees
legitimately it sounds hot but
once you get accustomed to it because
i've been doing it for months and months
like i started out i would do like 150
or 160 170
and then i went too high i got way over
like 220 i was in like the 220s
it was too hot i'd get i was cooking i'd
come out my throat would hurt
i'm like that's stupid laird hamilton's
a freaking nature i don't know what's
what the [ __ ] flowing through that
guy's veins he's got some
[ __ ] mercury flowing through his
veins but then i got to about 180 180 is
like tolerable
but if it's it's a struggle like if you
do 180 for a half an hour
ooh those last five minutes are rough
you want to get the [ __ ] out of there
like it's a little dance with your mind
you know you're telling you're telling
your body who the [ __ ]
is in charge here sit down and just deal
with it just breathe in
you have five minutes how are you gonna
get through this you're gonna get
through through breathing you wanna
listen to a book
to sit the [ __ ] down and deal with it
it's good
i like it that guy he's out he's a freak
leonard hamilton wears oven mitts and he
ch he cranks that [ __ ] up to 250 degrees
and rides an airdyne bike jesus
i'm a smell probably smells awesome
it smells like success smells like a
[ __ ] man
yeah he's uh he's a freak
crazy surfer man like some of the the
surfing [ __ ]
you watch him and he's just dedicated to
like continuing that lifestyle
keeping his body fit like deep into his
50s i think he's like 55.
dude's a savage going hard
out there in his 250 degree sauna with a
[ __ ] airdyne bike inside of it
very unusual dude man i mean you got to
be someone
really special to us that your number
one thing that you love to do
is ride hundred foot waves
[Laughter]
number one thing you want to do is
balance on the [ __ ] tip of the
ferocious nature of the ocean you're
balancing on the waves themselves you're
inside
the mouth of the most ferocious aspect
of the ocean the biggest waves
before they break on the shore and guys
like him like look at this man
[Laughter]
that you have to be a crazy person to
want to do that look at that
that's amazing i just want to get back
on [ __ ] stage
i know right man i know i don't want to
do a line of code
put that put those headphones on to me
and here's how i i don't want to [ __ ]
do
a show in a parking lot and i'm not of
course dominating for another four
months
that's like showing up with a line of
coke and leaving me alone
yeah [ __ ] you i'm ready to start from
scratch
i'm excited to do some bob gonzo shows
and just [ __ ] just do some creepy
[ __ ] again and then
[ __ ] work myself up to 30. get the
endurance
yeah it'll take a little while i'm not
gonna lie to you we're all gonna be a
little [ __ ] rusty do you have any
recordings
old ones um you should record your shows
on your phone
from now on it's not hard
that's great that way you can always go
back and you always know your material
it helps so important what i was
thinking five months ago
and what i'm thinking now is completely
different oh yeah for sure but what i'm
saying is you'll have bits
you'll have your bits you have whatever
you think it's now too
i don't ever want to say those bits
again they don't
whatever i was saying in february didn't
record it you got to record it it gives
a [ __ ]
i do it's what i feel from nowadays you
got to save it
we got to talk about what's going on now
what happened the last five months
the breakdowns to what happened
something had happened to your last five
months
you're gonna come back with some old bit
i'm gonna come back with gay bob
is my neighbor what kind of comic would
i be that's what the problem with comedy
is
i can't wait to watch a guy like you you
know who's gonna light that stage on
fire first
who bill burr bill burr's at home with a
new kid
four months you're never gonna see
anything like that the first time oh i
can't wait to hear him
talking about people you're not gonna
[ __ ] you
nobody's like i'm going to build
billboard out right now
he's at home with two kids first time
you know hasn't done dick whatever
great guy playing the drums in his
basement
he's gonna come at this with a complete
different outlook
he's going to attack somebody you know
somebody's going to go down
hard yeah you know there's guys that you
know a lot of people are going down hard
yeah we're going to go out there like
[ __ ] gang busters
well i just when do you think it's gonna
happen april
that's what i would say april so
they come up with some kind of a vaccine
right now they're saying january
but they're saying january and they're
winking at you
yeah it's by the time everyone gets
around getting it and everything i'd say
april also do you guys think they should
let people work
depends what type of job they're doing
yeah that they social distance you know
what
i love i'm a fat [ __ ] i don't go there
but uh that burger joint
um yeah in and out social distancing in
that
i just ate there the other day
distancing
those four feet do they make people wear
masks inside there masks and gloves and
they really try their best
but there's jobs that you just can i
went to get my hair cut done
for that that week that it was open it
was the
i thought the safest i've ever been
eating
they're [ __ ] the hair people right
now isn't it true that california is the
only state
like is that true california is the only
state that doesn't let hairdressers open
i saw that map i don't know
yeah is that true though i retweeted
that map i didn't even check and they
said that they only do it outside you
can't have a sink out so you can't cut
hair and windy outside [ __ ]
like it's the dumbest idea and then what
happens when it gets dark you gotta stop
and otherwise you can stay open till
eight nine at night and if they try to
do it in their
house they can't do you know a shield
so you have to have your hand through
the shield dip them in the water and
then they spread them
and then you have to have the thing you
know hey listen you ain't stopping
the vietnamese and [ __ ] orange county
yeah they're the ones that built those
tunnels for the mexicans
they don't [ __ ] stop those vietnamese
from orange county they're
opening shop they don't give a [ __ ]
there's been what about the dudes in
jersey they threw in jail
we're opening up the gym oh yeah
they're hitting them with some crazy
fines like fifteen thousand dollars a
day
they're gonna lose their license it says
you can get a haircut outside
as of july 20th 29th yeah
but no one's doing that right but what
and my and my friends do hair out here
they said that they can't even like have
you come to their house because if they
find out the hair association they'll
pull their license the question though
was is california the only state that
bans
doesn't it
doesn't but then again right if you're
if you're someone who's [ __ ] you can
make 600 bucks from the government or
you can take a risk of getting some
disease that might kill you
to clean someone's nails yeah but the
problem is from what i'm hearing is a
lot of people are not getting any
checks like they got one big one and
then they haven't heard anything for
months you can't call anybody you can't
get anything so it's like i have to pay
rent so
what am i going to do exactly i do i i
feel you 100
i don't have like when i look at this
there's i don't have a clear way out of
this
because i feel like if everybody just
went back to work more masks
how much quicker would the disease
spread people are working
like they used to be working side by
side with people just wearing masks how
much would it stop that
i don't know what does that look like i
mean is the only reason why there's not
a [ __ ] heap more dead bodies because
we killed the economy i don't know man
i'm too
stupid i like to think that's the way
reason
you know like it seems like that makes
sense
my worry is that they like telling
people what to do that's my worry people
like telling people what to do they love
it
stay inside do this do that wear a red
flag
you know wear a blue t-shirt people love
getting people to comply with everything
and if all of a sudden they have this
power to keep you from
comply with anything well i didn't have
to okay i got lucky
near did i but a lot of people did i go
to parties no no did i go to the park no
do want do i need to go to a bar not
really do i need to go to a restaurant i
don't even like [ __ ] sitting next to
people before kovitz
okay so you won't see me in a restaurant
so [ __ ] san san dinero
you understand me there's things that
are you know if you're gonna stand out
here with 40 people for a piece of
chicken
you should be shot and hung and then
shot again there's just certain things
you know i was very very very very very
and you know this upset about the
stand-up
and i pleaded with you not to go to
houston
i called brendan as a man i understand
the need
to need money but i don't understand the
need there's only one dave chappelle
so everybody should stay home and mind
their [ __ ] business nobody needs to
go on the [ __ ] road
because by hitting us like you going on
the road
we have a little power now we all stay
home there's covered it's time for you
to close
people are [ __ ] dying wherever the
rates the highest
arizona texas florida what three comedy
clubs are open
arizona florida listen i ain't pointing
my fingers
they're not giving you a [ __ ] fact
okay you never played it with me to not
go to houston there was no plea
no i told you that thursday i said mind
your [ __ ] business
and stay the [ __ ] this is what this is
really said joe rogan why are you going
to tell me why are you going to texas oh
my god when i go comedy
it's only 50 percent capacity no comedy
where you wearing a mask you come in
and then how did you call me on monday
i'm nervous i'm not going back on the
road no more yeah
i didn't say like yeah i cancelled the
rest of my tour
this is terrible i just got a blood test
i got my knees checked
once brendan and [ __ ] the other guy
got it
that sets you off a little bit oh it did
and you have children and you have a
wife and you have responsibilities well
here's the big thing
and you have here so guests if
i got you sick or you sick or you're not
jamie's sick or anybody working here
that that would be oh please
i thought you could do it like if the
health department says you can do it
and you know they they social distance
and you wear a mask and you could do it
but then i got there i'm like you
probably can you probably can like four
out of five times
or eight out of 10 times or 12 out of 15
times but you're gonna it's gonna get
you it's gonna get you
if you're in these large groups of
people and everybody's laughing like
what is
better at spraying a disease and you
know
you know what you're wrong part of this
game
is taking a picture with people yeah and
answering the question you know
it took away that alienation of it so
i'm done there
i'm done there i don't want six people
in the green room
i don't need the weights coming in i
don't need the guy coming in how much
time do you want to do
the music guy i don't need any they're
finding out now we're
doing this all the stuff we're doing all
this stuff by the book or
i won't do it i'll do it at certain
places
by the book needs to be examined like
what what by the book is my
book is i'm gonna sit in my [ __ ] car
three feet from the [ __ ] door
when i'm three minutes to go up you
knock on the [ __ ] door
i go in i do the comedy and i go back in
my [ __ ] car in between shows and i
take a ride
then i come back at 10 40 whenever you
be
seated and you do it again you can't go
in the [ __ ] green room with more than
because anything after three or four
people we got it
it's like going to a [ __ ] orgy you
got it
so now you're gonna go out there i don't
know about you but when i [ __ ] you
know when i was a kid people tell me
joey
give me the news not the weather i spit
when i talk
so i don't want nobody 10 feet it's
really
30 feet if you really think about the
distance
thirty point three thirty
something [ __ ] crazy something look
at my [ __ ] lungs
look at my stomach when i get excited
and i'm [ __ ] yelling i'm doing a
[ __ ] bit
this is
do you know what i smelt what do you
know what i smelt in my teeth
hair pubic [ __ ] hairs [ __ ]
the stinking my teeth when they drill
when they drill your mouth and you smell
your teeth burning and
whatever's stuck in between there you
know i mean it's a [ __ ] nightmare so
i don't even know what we're talking
about
this weed is strong shout out
i'm talking about that that that's my
concern
about stand-up comedy we're all gonna
get coping
eventually you're gonna get it we're all
gonna be strong enough
we're gonna survive that's okay my
thing is the social uncertainty the
one show where somebody gets up and says
[ __ ] you and somebody throws a bottle
and we have a problem
you know what we have too much of that
going on right now so for that
i will not go on stage until everybody's
settled
everybody is happy the vibe is better
go on you're going you're salvation
right now
in isolation is the internet and you go
on the internet
and you get off feeling even worse than
what you felt like
when you went on it it's true you avoid
the tv
if you have it in any intelligence level
right now
you have to avoid the tv and if you
throw down lemon on or the other [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's even [ __ ] worse don lemon i'll
sidekick him in the lung if i see that
[ __ ] he pisses me off
and chris cuomo crying what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you [ __ ]
i used to like him then he started
crying and [ __ ] like that he got him
and i had to stop watching all that
nonsense
abc news is not the most watched news
it's a [ __ ] business
it's a business and they're there to
petrify you yes so i turned all that
[ __ ] off
everything i'm cancelling facebook
pretty much
this is what i said very important well
you just said it's very important you
know
the news is a business it's a business
sorry guys
it's all over you know i'm done
i'm done if it was up to me joe rogan i
would have
moved to montana you know why didn't you
move to montana
that's the next move hold on i don't
know let's let's just get out of
california detox a little bit
and let's talk let's talk let's talk
okay let's get a ranch i say open up a
club in billings
i'm in that's a theater slash
tremendous comedy
okay let's call it uh hmm
just for so everybody knows where we're
coming from
a mini culture a mini a comedy mini
comedy mini car 60 man comedy guys who
believe in comedy that can be done
bring your wives bring your kids montana
everybody goes to regular schools
right but we all abide certain certain
comedy
no thieves right no king no people
[ __ ] i want emilio estevez to play me
really how crazy is that emilio
and when the movie came up he was too
old for the movie
and he used his brother charlie charlie
tremendous that's a tremendous god damn
what a good [ __ ] movie that was oh
great just to talk to you
there he is that's amazing
he's playing with your fingers i'm gonna
have to end this podcast
well i hope you're wrong about april but
whenever it is
we'll we'll be more appreciative i think
can an alligator survive
uh without eating yeah for a long time i
heard it they could never die from
starvation
is that real i don't know i know they
know that for sure
crocodiles have gone without eating for
a whole year what's with the crocodile
questions
somebody told me that i can't stop
thinking about it it's a solid question
because what if they don't starve death
they just shrink right and i also heard
lobsters but i heard that was fake
that lobsters don't have to eat oh
dude yeah that makes sense if you until
you like shrink
if you don't have enough food you get
down to like nothing right and then
you're down to one cell
wow that's interesting bro and just
shrink with cells
here it is they only can be killed by
starvation or accidents it says
crocodiles have no recognized finite
lifespan
instead they just get bigger and bigger
until they inevitably
they're inevitably killed out by
starvation accidents or disease
this is the reason we don't see
crocodiles the size of boeing 747s in
the wild
so if there was an unlimited amount of
food they would live forever and no
disease
we vaccinated crocodiles and gave them
an unlimited amount of food then there'd
be dinosaurs
they're basically dinosaurs didn't we
figure that out the other day that
crocodiles are as old as some dinosaurs
like dinosaurs
were like 65 million years ago but
crocodiles go back to like 100 million
years
wasn't that what it was so they're pre
they're dinosaurs
they're just still around they're just
hungry dinosaurs have you seen an
alligator in real life
yeah it's so confusing it's like why is
it right there
and why is everybody not freaking out 80
million years
so there you go wow so that's 15 million
years
older than when the asteroid hit and
killed everything
so they're [ __ ] dinosaurs
dude i remember seeing one for the first
time is at lake alice
it's in gainesville florida my dad was
going to school in gainesville
we were down there and uh went to this
lake you throw marshmallows in the water
and alligators come and get it
i was like this is the strangest [ __ ] in
the world there's a 10-foot lizard just
ate a marshmallow in front of me
and i'm i'm not even worried about it
like when in
the world is a [ __ ] giant dinosaur
like
feet in front of you and you're not
freaking out like
crocodiles were too mean they became too
dangerous and no one wanted them around
but alligators looked like crocodiles
but they're just
chill enough that people don't freak out
too much if they're around
that was their trick that's how they
stayed alive they just moved slower
moved slower and didn't attack as much
but they're [ __ ] everywhere man
if you live in florida you've got
alligators in your yard all the time
like people want to live in florida like
okay that's there's alligators out there
there's
a florida video of the day a baby
alligator and a bobcat duking it out
kind of going viral so i can't put it up
oh my god
look at that thing look at that cat it
gets a howl
it gets it yeah oh for sure it gets it
the big
cats and like caimans down in uh
oh my god bites them right in the head
yeah but big cats
like uh caimans that live down in the
everglade or not the evergreen to the um
amazon they eat
those leopards eat uh or jaguars they
eat crocodiles down there all the time
there's a whole bunch of videos of them
they jump in the water behind crocodiles
and bite them in the head
cats are the scariest
but at crocodile and alligator that's a
real live dinosaur just
chilling at your golf course
congratulations
it's like godzilla versus motla
so what are you going to do for your
birthday dog today's my birthday what
are you going to do this is my
celebration this is it
what are you doing with the wife you're
going down you're jumping up and down
we'll do something you know probably
like that
have you had an ihop burger yeah are
they legit no they're frozen
oh jesus christ that's bad i hop [ __ ]
pancakes i went to that pancake place in
burbank what a mistake
what which one shitty one the one
international house of banks oh
yeah oh my god that is [ __ ] hard that
place is bad
last time i had a good pancake was a
place in boulder you gotta go get some
real pancakes
ones that are not uniform i don't like
paint i'm not a big
syrup guy i used to be allergic to sarah
i love pancakes for the five minutes i'm
eating them
and then afterwards i feel like [ __ ] for
days yeah i think mcgriddle's enough i
don't that's
enough
i remember when they first came out you
and tate fletcher oh
they're so delicious people it's so
delicious you can't help yourself
you don't even care what's important the
fish sandwiches
i still
well don't look at it
but but you can't tell me that a
mcgriddle doesn't taste delicious
that's horrible delicious have you had
one
when they first came out it's a
delicious combination
with the mystery meat and the cheese oh
jesus christ and that that
fake syrupy spongy bread bun
it's good i could do a [ __ ] egg
mcmuffin if i have to i like
wendy's bacon water stuff [ __ ] i like
egg mcmuffin's brother
i'm really tired i'm like [ __ ] it i get
a mcgriddle i'm like i don't care
that's the pork give it to me mcgriddle
yeah you can get sausage or bacon right
you get a bunch of
mcgregor griddle yeah both no they had
that one sandwich that was the rib
maker and they
why do they ever take it off the menu if
people like it so much because they
limited time only because they mean it's
it's uh yeah they don't have
indonesia it's only it's like in season
it comes via woohead with a [ __ ] bat
on it
okay i was hoping it was like
they can only buy a large amount of
media uh not they can't buy it all the
time frequently
it's permanent on the menu in germany
so head over there yeah they don't like
manipulation over there
first thing down the menu all year
what are you doing you're manipulating
people's desires
[Laughter]
i don't think so they don't even allow
scientology in germany
good they won't allow them they're like
excuse me
what are you saying you're saying that
the guy who writes the science fiction
books
comes up with the best religion and you
don't want to pay taxes
that might be the worst german accent of
all time conspiracies about why it's not
on the menu all the time so
it's a deep debated topic probably
because it [ __ ]
kills you it probably kills you they
probably know that if they give it to
people 40 days as well they just start
dropping down
so they're like listen just just give
them 20 days of mcrib
problem solved if they if they buy
if they buy 20 days of big ribs then
they die the 36th
day there's no way they can connect us
once a month i get zapped into going to
get a happy
meal happy because of the toilets my
daughter wow
the [ __ ] is wrong with you there is one
what is wrong with you
i gotta go in there not since the
epidemic now we drive
and they always give her the wrong toy
anyway what's the right toy
the one that they advertise you [ __ ] not
the one
whatever i go there trying to get the
[ __ ] one
i don't know the other one and then i
gotta beat no
whale i didn't know there was so two
weeks ago i had to go in there
with the mask on and go can i talk to
somebody listen
i got a daughter the last two times you
come in here you advertise the emoji
but you gave them the [ __ ] this on
tick-tock what the [ __ ]
it is now and the manager said let me
help you out
and she gave me the toy i wanted and my
daughter was happy
but the last two times i even tell him
she's a girl
sometimes they ask you she a boy or she
a girl she came here for a certain
[ __ ] thing
and you gave us something else that's
misrep representation
misrepresentation so i had to go in
there and get fired up
and they finally i didn't know they had
different ones yeah they tell you
listen don't ask me didn't they try to
outlaw those some places
they tried to outlaw giving toys into
happy meals
because they're like none kids like them
too much it's forcing kids to eat bad
because they want that toy i give her
the apple slices three of those fried
listen
i grew up in a house where i wasn't
allowed to eat fast food only in miami
my cousins ate it so my mom didn't allow
it the only thing i was allowed to eat
was don't cook tonight called chicken
delight
i used to order that she would say
you're not gonna eat my rice and beans
not really
and also they'd be she got i wonder who
the [ __ ] that is
it's for me don't cook the night called
chicken belly five dollars oh my god
three pieces of chicken
some ruffled fries a little piece of
jelly in those days i was really wanted
to be american
so i dip my french fries in the jelly
that's what my gross days
when i was first came from cuba i don't
cook tonight
call it chicken the like joey what is
that cuban place that you took me to the
one that used to be
near my house in encino the one that's
on ventura
what is that what's that place called i
forget that there are three of them
they're three
different i don't go there i go to
cochinito but we we ate there once and i
had that garlic chicken with the raw
onions tremendous tremendous that's our
steak is the name of that
versailles yes i knew it i was just
just as you were pulling it up i feel
like i saw it first we're gonna go after
this remember
i'll go there i'd love that place if
they does it show
an image of that chicken with uh onions
with raw onions
it's a garlic chicken with raw onion
that's the pork
and he was there with john jackson god
damn it's good that's it right there
that's right there with the plantains
whoa there's something about latin food
right like there's almost like a there's
a pop to it
that like other like there's the spices
and [ __ ] for cuban food
cuban food like re really like
spicy spanish food just something about
the pop of those uh ingredients you know
what that [ __ ] garlic chicken with
the raw onions and that sauce
that's like a lemon sauce that they had
joey yeah
wasn't it like a lemony garlicky sauce
garlic lemon
goddess damn that was good kick in the
doorway within the four
four oh yeah don't hit me no more
what's up dawg it touching my hand cause
i love you i miss you
i haven't seen you in three [ __ ]
months listen if we all move to a
different place maybe we'll love each
other more and we'll get together in a
specific spot
i'm moving to texas too man i'm getting
the [ __ ] out of los angeles how long do
you move when
i maybe wait a while you know and i will
get their feet on
people people are really worried about
taxes joey i know they are
because they're talking about raising
them up so significantly
and lowering the police and defending
the police from the schools and
trust me i hear this from my wife every
night i get the [ __ ] yeah cutting the
education budget an education budget no
school all year
parents don't want to mix and match it's
tough i just want to correct
in a basement that's all i need it's
just 23 years joe rogan
i did more than i thought i'd ever do
you know what i was at the
store at a different time than kennison
and dice
and it was just as magical but sometimes
i'd rather not be willie mays and go
play for the mets
if willie mays was smart he would have
gone out with the san francisco giants
and that's exactly what i'm doing hmm
i'm not
gonna do tom brady you just won six
championships
now you want to go to tampa bay and do
what
there's a time to say goodbye she used
to say it best what's that lady we grew
up on
it's so nice we've had this time
together
just to have a laugh or sing a song
i have no idea who this is the worst
cowboy
[Laughter]
and before you know it it's the time we
have to say
so can i ask you this have you adapted
well
are you adapted have you listened to
what to do this is normal this is your
new life now
this is life this is this is what it is
don't stand up i miss stand up i
miss stand up i'm pulling the podcast
i'm ending the church the same way
i want to walk out like a man with my
feet instead of walking on my knees
i got some ideas
but my plan right now is to leave
quarantine for 10 days move into the
house
put my daughter in school shoot a couple
days in the sopranos
and then you and i will talk business
okay
you and i will call and we'll decide
what we're going to do yeah
if we go to montana red band it's going
to be colder the [ __ ]
it's cold we're going to print money
okay you need to learn how to chop wood
i
there's two or three places in montana
welcome us welcome us with a tax break
with the whole thing if we just opened
up a comedy club in montana
people would love to see brendan shaw
montana i would love to see
kill talk so why it's too easy and we
got to fight the alligators
probably hawaii is you couldn't even fly
there yeah
right right now if you fly there you
have to wait for two weeks yeah i think
that [ __ ] goes to september 1st doesn't
it something
along those lines and i want montana
because it's hard to get there it's a
connecting flight
yeah montana is a pain in the ass to get
to utah and the monsters got a great
it's going to make you stronger you're
going to be a stronger person what's
montana's weight loss
yeah august 11th reinstated beginning
august 11th mandatory 14-day quarantine
has been raised partial inter-island
quarantine reinstated okay
yeah they're not [ __ ] around in
florida or excuse me in hawaii they
don't want people to get it get on the
island
yeah i mean it makes sense yeah they've
they've got
they can't get away from it you know
it's like if they catch it on one of
those islands and it spreads through the
whole [ __ ] eye should they close
borders of every state
that's a good question man it's like
what if this listen per capita right now
arizona is the worst is it i called the
guy kidnapped the other night to check
in with him just to make sure you know
i'm a christian she's so sweet i heard
he was having a rough time so i called
him to see if he needed anything
and he told me he doesn't leave the
house because he's got his mom it's ptsd
he takes care of his mom so uh he's in
tucson
yeah arizona's uh he said that per
capita
it's the worst spot in the world he got
hit
he's very very scared so did you just
anywhere there's uh
my migrant workers they get hit anywhere
there's
uh you know people that don't believe in
mass they get hit
a lot of like churches people that want
to go to church they don't give a [ __ ]
they start singing in church they get
hit
it's like those are the people that get
hit like churches unfortunately people
when they say like you can't ban houses
of worship like
boy that's a tough one because
everybody's yelling
listen i want to go to church but church
is where your heart is anyway yeah
so enough with the church is where your
heart is but they need to make a
solution so i understand you have to go
and see and sing and dance but you know
what for right now
for right what's going on right now i
don't know what's in the
the constitution i don't know what's in
the federation
i don't know i'm just saying that for
right now if you want to have the
congregation
anything over eight people you're
playing with fire and even over six
people
but even then unless you know who those
where those people are they're living
with you fine
but if you don't know italy they should
figure out a way to do it outside
my friend who's a pastor in ohio does it
outside every sunday
totally could be done in a park yeah
they can do it you can do it outside
until it gets really cold out
yeah and then you're [ __ ] cold then
you gotta get a bonfire going
yeah then it's jesus bonfire every
sunday yeah that sucks right
stay out there when mittens on you're
eight like [ __ ] this dad
come on wait to the vaccine dad i don't
want to go to church by the bonfire
this doesn't mean nothing real think
about i mean i hate to
keep us going for a second here but
think about how weird this has been like
doing these podcasts over these years
that's changed all of our lives
now how weird it is you just talk into a
microphone
just talk [ __ ] and do it over and over
and over and over again
and people just enjoy episodes what's
your new thing going to be
after you do the church what are you
going to call it i do not know yet
i'm thinking of different ideas called
the new testament
no i'm gonna take your kick show ideas
first of all
first of all i'm gonna take your thing
of using my name
okay you've always told me to use my
name absolutely
who's your name i think it's either
gonna be uncle joey something with uncle
joey
uh uncle joey diaz uncle joey powerhouse
that's great you know i don't know i
don't know what i want to do yet
let me figure out these steps to the
24th or whatever
okay but whatever you do here's
something you have to do
go ahead you have to sell you know me
dog shirts
okay you know me shout out shirts you
know me dog
because i mean nine out of ten of all
the [ __ ] best stories you've ever
told me
start with you know me dawg this and you
know me
dog when the story gets crazy if you
just had a shirt that says you know me
dog
that would be a gigantic hit get right
guaranteed
absolutely do it before those [ __ ]
hyenas out there
the people that listen to this you got a
guy who does t-shirts right
yeah make that [ __ ] up a shirt
that says you know me dog
i guarantee you they'll sell like crazy
and spirits spirit
is a good one too spirits with
exclamation point
all right i love you listen i love you
guys i love you guys thank you very much
bye everybody
me too i am about to die